Hello, hello everybody.
Hello, hello.
Um, I will say, um, the reason why we pushed the stream an hour late was because of me.
It was me, all along.
But it was because, um, I couldn't find... I'll tell the full adventure.
I tell... I'll tell the...
Because, like, everybody else was streaming except for me.
So, like, I think everyone could sort of tell it was because I wasn't there.
Because everyone else started their individual streams except for me.
But it was actually because, um, I couldn't find my game capture.
I spent the last four hours trying to find my game capture.
Um, then some of you guys might be wondering, oh, Doki, why didn't you...
Why didn't you try to find it earlier?
Well, it's because I had to take...
If you guys didn't know, um, I won't tell this when everybody...
I was gonna tell...
I'm gonna tell the full story when everyone's here.
I asked if I could and they're just like, yeah.
Um, but I did have to take Dad to the hospital for his CT scans in the morning at 7 in the morning.
So after I took him for his CT scan, I went and took a nap because I was so fucking tired.
Because it's, like, basically, like, we leave him, um, throughout the day.
So, because of that, I went to bed and, like, I went back to take a nap.
And then when I woke up, it was, like, 1, um, it was, like, 1 p.m.
And that's when I started searching for my game capture.
Um, that's what I said.
So, you know, I was like, don't worry.
It'll be fine.
I can find it.
And then, um, and then, you know, as the hours ticked by, I was like, wait a minute.
You know, like, maybe I can't find it.
Yeah.
Yes, it was moved by, I forgot that my cleaner, like, moved it.
So, so, so, yeah.
So, that was sort of a big issue.
Okay, so apparently, um, oh my gosh.
Wait, okay, I need to do my friends list real quick to make sure I have everybody.
Did they add me yet?
I don't know.
Wait, let me, I was gonna, I'll tell the full story.
I'll tell the full story on stream, too.
All right, I got Mari.
Okay, Mari added.
All right, I said if I could tell the full story on stream and they said it's okay.
Okay, so I'll tell the full story of how I got my game cap.
Clearly, my game capture to end up working.
Um, I have no idea who Greninja is.
It's someone I bumped into Splatoon a long time ago.
I was like, oh, hey, Greninja.
Who the fuck is that?
Oh my god, I got another friend request right after.
Okay.
I got, um...
I got another friend request right after.
I'm pretty sure that is from...
Okay, no, actually, that's not...
Hello?
Okay, I am making sure all the foogie's up now.
Let me grab the foogie.
Um...
Yeah?
No, don't worry.
My chat knows.
My chat, I told them.
I was like, we all waited for me.
Everyone was streaming but me.
So, it's deductive reasoning.
We can tell why we pushed this stream.
They're like, oh, wow.
They pushed the stream and now I wonder why.
Wait, Zen's streaming.
Oh, Fillion's streaming.
Oh, MariMari is streaming too.
But where's dookie?
Where is dookie?
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Um, but yes, thank you for giving me your time so I can tell the full story.
So I can defend myself.
Um...
If we're in court right now, I will defend myself.
As to why the stream was pushed back an hour.
Um...
That's fair.
In front of a public audience.
Uh, all right, let me make sure.
Oh, so, hey, Zen.
I heard your thing got an upgrade.
Yes, it did.
Oh, my God.
It's so fast now.
Whoa.
How's it going?
Look at you go.
Yeah, look at that ping.
What's the ping?
Is it like 10 ping now?
10 MS?
A little bit faster.
Whoa.
So it's like, oh, my God.
You literally live next to the servers now.
So fast.
Yeah, it's so fast.
All right.
Feels good.
Yeah.
Okay, sound guy.
Help me balance everybody.
Now I can make fun of everybody really fast.
Ooh.
Can you cook me?
No.
How?
You're talking about a knot smack for a toaster.
All right.
Hello, Mari.
I am always cooking then.
All right.
Let me...
Hi, Mari.
Now that everyone is here, I shall defend myself as to why I'm...
Why?
You're really inviting us all to cook you publicly for content right now.
You know that, right?
Okay.
If you're setting us up...
Okay, so...
Explain.
Okay, so the reason why...
All right.
So...
So I started my...
It was because of me and it was because...
Long story short, it's because I couldn't find my game capture.
But...
But there was more.
There's more to this story.
So I started searching for my game capture at 1 p.m.
And I figured, like, oh, it's gonna be easy, you know?
Like, it's...
Everything is in my...
It's Nintendo Switch.
Everything is in my office.
It should be fine.
But the thing is, the thing I forgot was that I have cleaners because I don't have a control of my life.
So I...
So...
It's okay.
Come in here...
We're not adults.
Once a month.
Yeah, so, like, we all understand, right?
Like, as a streamer, we all need extra help.
So...
So I have cleaners that come here...
One cleaner that come here once a month to, you know, help me control my life and make sure I don't live like, you know, live like XQC.
Girl, there was no controlling your life.
So, because of that...
It is all fucked.
We are all fucked.
They sent in a new...
That's not true.
Not me.
Okay, how's your office, Mari?
Mari, how about you put a girl on?
Yeah, what's...
Why don't you put a girl on?
How's my office?
It's beautiful.
Do you want to see a picture of it?
It's gorgeous and clean and pristine.
Wait, you're going to send a picture?
Wait, do you want to see?
There's no way.
I showed it on...
I literally...
You're searching that.
I showed a stream...
I showed a picture of it on stream the other day.
Wait, you sub-boxed.
Okay, but what did it look like before you cleaned that office?
I...
Okay, well...
I don't need your sass, okay?
Yeah, dude, that's like the one time you spent eight hours cleaning up.
Yeah, like you finally cleaned up your office and then you took a picture of it.
But what was it like before?
I just had to...
I had to take...
What the fuck?
15 monster energy zero ultra cans off my desk before that.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay, there, there.
See, point proven.
You can...
Wait, don't show that one.
Oh, yeah, that...
Your Discord's leaking.
Yeah.
Don't show that one.
Okay, but when was this picture taken?
Uh, like...
Like six days ago?
Two weeks ago.
How about take a new picture?
Yeah, how about a new picture?
What does it look like?
Do you want a picture right now?
A new picture right now?
Okay, I'll take a picture right now.
What does it look like?
No makeup.
I will have to say, my desk right now has like seven different bottles of drinks surrounding my desk.
They're all empty.
But you guys can't make fun of me.
Don't worry, my cleaner's coming in, like, next week, so everything will be okay.
I got too many water bottles.
Oh, yeah?
Well, I cleaned my room.
And on my desk...
I'm a fish.
Saba?
We only have pickled quail eggs and an empty jar of grape jelly from Smucker's.
Wait.
You eat pickled quail eggs?
Oh, I did the one stream and I never took it off.
Awful, by the way, just so you, uh...
It's like eating a pink smell.
Okay, okay, it's...
What's flesh inside of it?
I'm sending it.
It's not even that bad.
Okay.
Cool.
Wait, look.
No, no, no, no, no!
Look, look.
It's just not even that bad.
It's not even that...
Okay, but that's like basically a week.
Wait.
Wait a s...
Wow.
Wait a minute.
You know what, Mari?
I can't even cook you for that.
What the...
Who are you?
That's...
That's what I'm saying.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can't...
No, no, no, no, no.
I can't show you.
Do you live...
Do you live with your parents?
No.
Okay, okay.
I was gonna say maybe your parents helped out.
Hey.
What do you take me for?
I don't know.
This doesn't look like a streamer's test.
That's all I'm saying.
I wish my mom would clean my room.
I love my mommy.
And she's very good at cleaning.
She can get blood stains out of anything.
All of our chats are cooked right now, by the way.
How do I get her name?
Listen to your listening.
Okay, okay.
My mom's name?
Wait, what?
Are you trying to dox your mom?
No.
Can you dox your mom's name?
Cashmere just leaks it.
No.
Okay, okay.
Anyway, so back to my story.
Back to my story.
Okay, back to my story.
Back to your story.
Yes, yes.
Anyway, so my cleaner, they assigned me a new cleaner.
And then she was like, wow, it's so messy.
You want me to rearrange everything?
Did your last cleaner die?
No, I don't know.
They never...
She just showed up.
She's like, hello, I'm your new cleaner now.
And I was like, okay.
You got reassigned?
What is the Wizard of Oz cast?
I got reassigned.
Like, it's not that bad.
Okay, it's not that bad.
My place is not that bad for them to quit on me.
But she was like, is it okay?
I'm using that a lot.
It makes me worried.
Yeah, I thought I'm one of us talking.
Look, okay, look.
It's very hard to take care of myself, okay?
And anyway, so...
So I thought it would be okay.
Because, like, you know, it was very messy.
So I was like, it's fine.
You can rearrange everything.
Little did I know, when she rearranged everything, she literally moved everything around.
So I didn't realize how bad it was until, like, today.
Because I couldn't find...
First off, I couldn't find my Switch.
Because it was stuffed in a cupboard that's not even in my office.
And I was like, how the fuck did that get there?
And then I realized none of the cables were connected.
There were no cables next to my Switch.
So I was like, where did she put my cables?
Um, so from there, I had to find my GameCapture, all my Switch cables, the cables for my GameCapture as well.
And that was, like, four hours of, like, just looking, trying to dig around my house.
The cables was in a fucking box that was located in the corner of my living room.
And filled with clothes, by the way.
There were cables with the clothes box.
And then...
What the fuck does your house sound like?
Like a maze?
Yeah.
The fuck?
And honestly, it just sounds like a hoarder's paradise.
Oh, no.
I never unpacked since I moved.
I probably went to the kiddie pool in there.
So, I don't know.
There's, like...
There's, like, um...
Like, 15 boxes in the corner of my living room.
Because I've never unpacked.
Why?
Other than my...
So, when people visit, you look like you're effing out of Breaking Bad.
And if they find your meth lab, you gotta move out.
Like...
Like, the only thing I literally unpacked was, like, software streaming.
Like, literally, my PC and my desk.
Somebody was cooking here.
And, yeah.
So, then, like...
I finally found all my cables and my game capture that was stuffed in, like, my clothes box for some reason.
And then I tried connecting everything to my PC.
And for one...
I was doing one hour troubleshooting.
Because I was like, I found it.
I don't have to go out and buy a new game capture.
Thank fucking God.
Because they're expensive.
And then, like, I plugged everything in.
None of it were working.
So, I was like, maybe it needs a Nintendo Switch HDMI cable.
Because I was...
I had, like, a random HDMI cable.
that I found.
And then...
That didn't work.
I was like...
And I had to open...
I was like, okay, I can't find my Nintendo Switch HDMI cable.
Maybe a PlayStation 5 HDMI cable will work.
So, I had to unpack my unopened PS5.
Because I never had to use it.
I grabbed the PS5 HDMI cable.
Wait, you have a PS5 that you've never opened?
I've never opened because there was no games on the PS5.
You don't understand.
What?
There's...
There's no games on the PS5.
So, there was no reason to unpack it.
You should have sold it, bro.
Like, I'm just hoping there's new games.
Okay.
Africa could have eaten that junk.
Eventually.
Eventually, there will be new games.
I'm just waiting on that.
So, I unpacked...
No.
The PS5 HDMI cable.
When did the PS5 come out?
I don't know.
It was been like...
I think five plus years.
Five years ago.
Five plus years.
It's not happening, bro.
You just gotta sell it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's too late.
I already opened it.
I kept it.
I'm gonna go back and finish it.
I kept it mid-conditioned for like a year.
And I haven't opened it.
And then I had to open.
I literally ripped the box open because I was so stressed out.
I was so stressed out.
I literally ripped open the box too.
So, the box is not salvageable anymore.
You could have thrown out a homeless person.
But yes.
After that, it still didn't work with my PS5 HDMI cable.
And that's when I was like yelling in our group chat being like, what can I do?
And then finally, after four hours and one hour of troubleshooting, I fixed it.
Because all I had to do was unplug the Switch controller charger that was plugged in my Switch.
Yes.
And after I unplugged that, my game capture finally worked.
Like, I...
I'm not gonna ask how.
I don't know how that was interfering with everything.
Like, I just wanted to play on my Switch controller because we're playing Mario Party.
Because, Doki, you tried to use a Switch.
That was your first mistake.
I mean...
This game was your idea!
You suggested the game!
Bro!
Zen picked the game!
It's not that hard!
Zen, do you play a lot of the Switch games?
I love Mario.
Here and there.
I would never say that.
Okay.
Here and there.
Yeah.
Okay.
See, like...
Like, Doki, like, it's just...
It's a skill issue on our part, okay?
Like, we need to use our Switch more.
Like, if we're not supporting Nintendo, then we're already...
Okay, listen.
I'm not trying to get copyrighted by Nintendo.
Oh, true.
Yeah, Chad, today we're playing Mori Party.
Yeah, we're playing Mario Party.
It's not actually, like, Roy at the Nintendo.
I was just talking about the...
How many penis jokes am I allowed to make?
I think it's fine.
Today.
Okay, well, I mean, this isn't a joke.
This is a penis fact.
If they're gonna...
I mean, like, so...
Calm down.
She's got a fact.
I've got a penis fact.
I was just talking about how there was...
I don't know if it was a company or an individual, but they made a mock-up for a Bowser-themed dildo.
And Nintendo...
I don't know if they sued the living shit out of them, but they got it taken down by Nintendo.
Well, most likely, because, like, Nintendo has a lot of lawyers in general.
Yeah.
100%.
Yeah, I mean, like...
It's because Nintendo wanted the design for themselves.
Did you...
Yeah, after the Pokefreak leaks...
I mean, didn't you see the Donkey Kong shit where you can, like, sculpt anything in the Donkey Kong thing?
And someone literally made a Donkey Dong and got DMCA'd by Nintendo.
Wait, they got DMCA'd inside of their own game?
No, they...
Yeah, they got banned off of the Nintendo Switch 2.
So they got banned off of the, like, online features on Nintendo Switch 2.
After he tweeted the picture out.
He didn't even upload it or anything.
He just tweeted the picture out and his account got banned.
Uh-oh.
Because he made the Donkey Dong.
We'll get a phone call from Nintendo.
I don't know who you are.
And I think it DMCA'd the picture, too.
Yeah, the Nintendong.
No Nintendongs allowed.
That's why Donkey Kong's not naked anymore.
Wait, what?
She's not naked?
His default outfit has tags on.
Did you ever see the original animated one?
Oh, the Donkey Kong Country animated series?
Yeah.
Yeah, I love that series.
With all the songs.
I'll shower you in coconut cream pies.
But it's so good.
Yeah.
Also, who is making...
It is really good.
Who's making the lobby for this game?
Oh, I don't think any of us know what we're doing.
I think Zen is, like, our parent today.
Oh, yeah, Zen.
You have to add me, by the way, Zen.
Oh, you are...
Everybody add Doki, and then we enter her lobby.
Oh, that's true.
Because I already added her.
Yeah.
Okay.
Add me.
I'm waiting.
I'm going to try to make sure my junk is working real quick.
I mean, because obviously it is, but yeah.
You know, one sec.
It's working.
Did you not fucking test me?
Your lovely lady junk?
When I get my hands on you.
Science team?
Oh, yeah?
Come and put your hands on me, huh?
I'll push you over.
Can I close my eyes before you guys do anything crazy?
No.
You have to witness this.
Okay.
You have to witness my glorious victory.
Oh, it's working.
It is working.
So who are we stealing the star from?
Zen?
What?
Not it.
I call Zen.
Oh.
But actually, no.
We should just steal Fillion's.
He's the one that has the least experience in Nintendo.
I like your idea.
Let's do it.
What is this?
An effing Kendrick versus Drake?
Brother, like...
Wait, which one are you?
Fillion, I've never...
Which one are you?
Choose your sides carefully.
Fillion, I don't think I've ever seen you play a video game ever.
So I feel like you're kind of the weak link here.
Doug, I beat you on chess.
It's true.
Wait, what were you...
Yeah, Fillion, what were you doing before this?
We never played chess, bro.
Because I beat you.
What are you saying, Dougie?
What were you doing before this?
Ow.
Fillion?
Oh, I was...
Were you watching videos?
Fillion beats me.
I was reacting.
I was playing was Waldo IRL.
So, yeah.
That's just reacting.
Okay.
Oh, yeah?
Did you tell me what the flag of Tunisia looks like?
Why would I need to know what the flag of Tunisia looks like?
Because what if you got Fortnite dropped out of the battle bus in a random location blindfolded and you had no idea where you were?
Well, to do that, I have to go outside first.
Okay.
Yeah, whatever.
Fine.
Okay.
It's fine.
How do you invite...
Just invite me.
Mom, please come on, boy.
I'm waiting for Zen to add me.
What did I do?
Zen added me.
Don't...
Don't be against me, please.
I need a teammate.
But you beat me.
I have sent.
You just said you beat me.
You just admitted to everybody that you beat me.
Yeah, you were pretty nice and moderating me.
Are you gonna beat me if I'm not on your side again?
No, no.
If we team up, then we can beat them.
Will you not beat me if I'm on your side?
Why are you making this freaky, bro?
I'm not a Discord moderator.
I am booting up my Switch game.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
How do I...
Do I have time to go pee?
Yeah, you do.
Because I still have to...
Move for it.
I have to wait for Zen to invite me.
Alright, Zen.
I'm connecting to the internet.
I'm connecting it.
Waluigi.
I did some Waluigi.
I'm connecting it.
Okay.
I got Shy Guy.
Alright.
Wait, can I be Boo?
I don't think anyone else is playing Boo.
Yeah!
I love Boo.
Boo for it.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'm trying to remember how to do this.
It's been so long.
Same aft.
Alright.
At chat.
How do I join someone...
Oh, join the party.
Is that the blue?
Did you say at chat?
Yeah, at chat.
They're my at grok.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, I'm talking to you to create the room.
Yeah, you have to create the room.
Zen, you're our parent.
Please help.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I wait.
Gotta go get the milk.
Sorry.
No!
We have to play Tic Tac Tover for hours.
Mom?
Really bad at that game.
Um, actually.
Just put the circle in the center.
Okay.
That's all you have to do.
Room's open.
Okay.
Let me...
The room's open?
I thought it was the left bottom corner.
Hey, joining room.
Yeah, I do the corners too.
I found it.
I caught a lot of them.
I think I'm joining.
Alright, you guys can join off of me now.
Hi.
So, what's the room?
Um, you just do like...
Wait, did I zen make the room?
Just do join room and then you'll find the room.
Oh, I'm gonna hide in the street.
There's the...
Well, there's no code on it.
It's literally just joining off of your friends.
Yeah.
I know, but I need to leak all...
I don't want to leak all my friends.
There's like a lot of them, so...
And all of them are playing Mario Party?
We're not friends.
We're not even friends yet.
Okay.
No, we are.
I added you.
Yeah, but I gotta...
I don't know what to accept the friend request.
Oh, you go to home and then click on your profile picture.
And then you should be able to...
Oh, friends are just...
Oh, add friends.
Oh, I have two friends request.
Hello.
Doki, yeah.
All right, welcome back, Mario.
Just join off of...
Join off the room.
Wait, you all blind here?
Yeah.
Fillion.
What?
I have two friends now.
I went from zero friends online to two.
This is the best day of my life.
Wait, you...
When was the last time you played on...
on the Switch?
This is a big day.
I'm...
Wait, have you never played Mario Party?
I'm on the team?
I'm...
Uh...
Have you never played Mario Party, Fillion?
Like, how do you have zero friends?
I'm telling you, Fillion's never played a video...
Wait, Mario, are you not even her friend?
Are you just an associate?
I'm not her friend on Switch.
No, we've...
We've literally never played a game together.
Fillion just brings me on and forces me to do bits with her.
And you added in such a bad life.
No, I love it.
I love you.
Thank you.
You don't need a table to say that?
The absolute shit of her now.
Yippee!
I'm a ghost.
Wait, are we playing?
Yeah, we're playing.
Kestars.
Holy frick.
Mods, quit this, bro.
All right, Zen, we're selecting everything.
Mods, quit this.
By the way, I'm playing...
Fillion's great adventure.
I'm playing off of my OBS screen.
Do you guys want the worst map or the best map?
Mods, twist her balls off.
Oh, this map fucking...
No, no, please.
That map sucks.
The best map of the worst map?
We should do Wiggler's Woods.
Wiggler!
Wait, we have Fillion, so we should play, like, the easiest map.
You're a clanker.
What are you saying?
You can't...
You real...
Did you just say that to Zen?
No, I said to Toki, so it's fine.
That doesn't make it...
In front of Zen?
Wait, Zen, do you...
Do you give her the pass?
I am telling your mom.
Oh, she didn't give you the pass, Fillion, so you're not allowed to say that.
Yeah, that's really fucked up.
Yeah, she didn't give you the pass.
What do you prefer to be called?
Just Zen.
Okay, whatever.
Alright, Zen.
Which one are we there?
Zen, do I have the pass?
Do you guys want the worst map or the best map?
I want a media map.
The worst one.
The best one.
Do the Bowser one, not the Bowser one.
This is the worst one?
No, Western Land is awesome.
Did you watch Star Wars?
Wait, which one?
There's so many Star Wars.
I've played Lego Star Wars.
Hi.
Okay.
Then you got it.
Yippee.
Can I get one handicap star?
Wait, can I get one too?
No.
Wait, you guys need handicaps?
I'm toad.
Can I throw a negative one star?
I'm toad number one.
Worst map.
Here we go.
How's this the worst map?
Wait, wait, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Sorry, in advance.
How long does the game take a Mario Party?
Like, two hours?
No, it's like...
It's kind of short now.
An hour and a half?
Oh.
Yeah, like an hour and a half.
An hour and a half?
Yeah.
I mean, it depends on who logged in.
Depends on how many stars we have to get.
Like, you don't want to be stuck with us for an hour and a half because you freaking hate us.
No, we should play six games.
Oh, no.
That's going to take literally eight hours, Millian.
Do you not like us?
Six hours.
You know what?
You know, I just thought it was weird that you were just doing six games and not ten games.
Guys, impromptu subathon.
Make sure to donate.
We'll all keep streaming.
Wait, who I do?
Two.
Ah, you should have given me the handicap bonus.
What do I do?
Yay.
Press A.
What?
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay.
Well.
Whatever.
I don't even care.
I don't car.
Guys, I'm blind and I'm first.
Good for you.
That will change very fast.
Mari, you're on my team, okay?
Watch me lead us with example.
Oh, okay.
Here we go.
I didn't realize we were doing teams.
That's me.
Millian, you're not going to backstab me, right?
Oh, she will.
What am I, Kesha?
No, of course not.
Let me just...
Here?
Kesha?
How old are you, bro?
What do you mean, Kesha?
There's a song called Backstabber.
Okay, fine.
I'm going to say some other stuff that Zen won't approve of.
So, it's either that or be a boomer.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Okay, I'm first.
Here we go.
Okay, lock in.
So, what do I do?
I got my controller.
I can look around.
Dice block.
Do I just...
Here?
Yeah.
Now what?
Just hit it.
Wait, have you...
What?
Oh!
She got a luck box, though.
What is this?
It's a luck box.
Blah!
Give me some money.
Yeah, you get...
Oh, you get an item.
Oh, you get to steal...
Wow.
Yeah.
You got the worthless one.
Congrats.
Now that's true.
To be fair, I feel like she won't even know how to put it down.
So, I think that's fine for us.
Wait, when do I put it down?
Nobody tell her.
Nobody tell her how to put it down.
Goodbye.
Let's see.
Let's view the board.
Wait, how many do I have left?
Do you guys like going outside?
Oh, actually...
Yes.
I do.
Good.
Yeah.
I like, uh...
Oh, my God.
Are you the fuck out of the map?
I like running really fast.
How fast can you run?
Uh, faster than you.
Okay, well, I'm faster than speed, so...
Well, I'm faster than that.
Get out of the fucking map!
I'm faster than Ashen Hall.
I don't even know who that is.
What are you doing?
I'm trying to get out of the map and won't let me!
Oh, my God!
And you guys are blaming me!
I made my turn in 10 seconds!
Doki Bird, more like Doki Boomer.
Oh, my God.
Come on, Ant.
What's happening?
I mean, the controls do kinda suck sometimes on this coin.
Okay, there we go.
You're an apologist!
Finally!
Fuck!
I was like, let me go!
Ha ha!
Who want to?
Get to the next station?
I don't wanna, man!
Is that the midnight train?
I don't wanna.
Can now say the fuck word at...
...Youtube.
Nope.
Did you hear?
What happened to YouTube?
Yeah, what happened?
Is the bird the word?
Apparently, you can say the word fuck now at the beginning of your seven seconds.
Wait, really?
Oh, yeah.
They changed that.
Chat, I'm gonna say it.
Seven three.
You weren't allowed to say fuck in the first seven seconds?
Yeah, you get demonetized if you do.
Oh.
I guess I never tried.
It's the same with, like, YouTube videos, too.
That's why, like, in the first...
I think, like, for YouTube videos, like, in the first seven seconds, they just, like, let an intro play so people don't have to worry about it.
Oh.
Somebody told me it was a good day for Australians then.
Not sure what that meant.
Because Australians curse a lot, probably.
Yeah.
Yeah, they have two words.
One starts with an F and one starts with a C.
Oh.
Cunt.
Cuck.
She got it.
Oh.
I'm allowed to say it.
I used to be the Prime Minister of Australia.
Minigame.
Wait, what?
Uh-huh.
What is this?
Wait, how did you get overthrown?
No.
What?
Hot, hot, hot.
What is this?
What's happening?
I think this is the one where you don't fall in lava.
It's game time.
It's been nine months since I played Mario Party.
Mario Party.
You gotta jump.
You just jumped over it.
Oh, you just jumped.
No, it's okay.
I just died.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
No worries.
I've been training my whole life for a bit.
Oh, I should have just practiced.
Maybe I shouldn't play off of my OBS screen.
No worries.
I've been training my whole life for a bit.
Okay, so I jumped.
Yeah, isn't it cute?
You should go pet it, billion.
Wait, oh, I got it.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, it's a good thing.
Look at me!
Whoa.
Okay.
Whoa, there's so many.
Just watch out for the giant flaming hippos.
They look pretty hungry.
Whatever the fuck those things are.
I think they're snakes.
I can't see my character.
Help.
Yippee.
Wait, what happens if we all live?
Um, then we all get first place.
Then it ties.
Then we all get coins.
Guys, guys.
We can win together.
Yeah.
Why are you stepping on me?
Vance.
Why did half of the human population get wiped out?
I took you down with me.
Just run straight into it.
Okay.
I won.
Fuck.
I died?
I'm the blue.
Aww.
It's okay.
Zen and I...
I took Zen down with me accidentally.
Did you grab her?
I stomped on her front.
I ran straight into it with my stupid...
God fucking...
Turned two out of ten.
Who turns?
Hey!
Wario!
It's a plumber.
I don't think Wario is a plumber.
Are they all plumber?
He's a...
He also has the biggest ass in the game.
Yeah.
It's true.
Oh my god.
Have you seen his behind in the new Mario Kart?
It's exquisite.
What?
Are you guys straight or something?
Don't know how they keep doing it.
But they keep doing it.
They really just keep making it bigger.
They polished it up.
Damn.
He really do be farting with that thing.
Oh, this is me.
This is me.
Okay.
So, I have items.
Yes?
Okay.
Now what?
Are you guys all ahead of me?
You probably are.
No, we're fine.
Do not see Toad right behind you?
No, no, no.
I'm gonna save my trap for when the time is right.
Wait.
And I'm gonna jump.
Okay.
Make them away downtown.
Walking fast.
Faces fast.
You should go up because...
Why?
Because it's closer to the star.
I...
What does the red square do?
Uh...
You should find out.
I don't know.
It's really nice.
I think it's...
It's a trap.
I think it swaps you with someone else if you land on it.
No!
Yeah.
Do it.
Wow, you guys really are Retubers, huh?
What is this gaslight?
Get on the red.
Thank you, Palpatine.
Do it now.
No!
Five soft.
I think that extra star.
I don't know.
I'm not going to always pick that.
Fillion, you need to take one for the team.
Awwww.
How are we going to ever know it?
How are you gonna get your star then?
I...
Why are you gonna get your star?
But...
Oh, but why did you ask then?
Why does it ask what it does?
I can roll whatever number I want?
What the frick?
What's the point of asking your opinion?
You're not gonna take our suggestions.
Yeah.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
You don't trust us?
I thought we were all friends.
Well... I don't have enough coins.
No, I don't have enough coins.
How many coins do you need?
20?
Like 50.
Uh-oh.
You got spotlighted.
20 coins.
I ain't gonna get hit by a train!
You wanted the Danganronpa?
No, she could buy...
Yeah, she just shifted it.
You know, it's impressive, though, that in, like, the almost 30 years of Mario Party being around, stars have never gotten any more expensive.
I know, there's no inflation.
They're following the Costco hotdog.
Yeah, I know.
Amazing.
That's great.
Can I get rid of it?
I've never had a Costco hotdog.
Is it good?
What?
It's delicious.
It's so good for, like, the price it is.
Yeah.
How much?
$1.50 for a dog and a drink combo.
Brokey.
Dude, this is fucking bullshit.
I went to the movie theaters the other day, and the hotdogs were, like, $5.
That's what I'm saying.
You've got to get to Costco.
Dude, fuck me.
Oh, my God.
Five American dollar dollars?
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, you can't wait.
I...
I need to be so for real with you.
I've gone to Costco before the movie.
And stuffing the hotdogs in my bag.
Just...
I've done...
Yes.
Do it.
I've done the same exact thing.
It's worth it.
$1.50?
Oh, but you need a Costco membership.
When you pull out the hotdogs, they're all crinkled and squished.
It's okay.
It tastes better that way.
Just put in...
No, put in, like, those, like, little boxes.
Exactly.
Those little containers.
Container.
Oh, good idea.
I didn't sneak it in.
What are they gonna do?
Check your bag?
Are they supposed to put up your hotdogs for hotdogs?
It's a free country.
I like my dog squished.
Uh...
I'm going.
Come on.
Um...
Mahari?
Ten.
Wait.
But do you guys like eating your hotdogs plain?
No, I like a hotdog with my ketchup, typically.
Mustard, ketchup, onions...
I have to eat my hotdogs plain.
Why?
Really?
I'm sorry.
Why do you like your dogs being naked?
Yeah.
Plain.
Why play?
Wait, why do you eat food?
But it's so juicy.
Ooh.
Is that even with onions?
Do I eat food so I can fucking move?
What is this game?
I thought you were a toaster!
Double the coins!
Flynn, you're being awfully...
You still gotta put stuff in toasters.
How about you stop at a Tesla station?
And charge?
I mean, technically.
What is this?
Wait, are we dead?
Guys, don't leave me!
I'm really scared!
Just grab as many coins as you can.
Check this out.
Which means I'm taking all of your coins.
Get out of my...
I died so I could play the actual game.
It's okay.
Just like the simulations.
Start!
Start, though!
Alright.
Glass, I'm taking the early lead.
Stop!
Ah!
Oh, you fell off.
Stop fighting.
Stop fighting!
What do you mean stop fighting?
Oh, I fucking fell.
Okay, I'm bringing my monitor up.
I can't play on real piss.
I got a coin!
I got the coin!
Who the frick is Shy Guy?
Oh, she's good.
Who is Shy Guy?
Wait, who died?
I just fucking disappeared.
I realized that that was a mistake.
We are whine.
It's okay.
I'm the hard carry.
Don't worry, kittens.
Boom!
Shot through Stacey.
And you guys slaved me!
Wow.
I am a beginner.
I thought you said you didn't play.
Beginner's luck.
I'm putting the monitor up now.
I'm playing on my lap.
Cause I don't have space on my desk.
Get a new gamer chair.
Mine's way better.
Huh?
Wait, I can buy a star now?
No, only if you get to it.
Whoever gets there first.
I'm gonna get to it.
I'm gonna touch it.
Wait a second.
I can just do...
Wait, how do I...
Board?
I'm bored?
Okay, so...
One, two, three...
Custom dice.
Don't say that!
And then roll a one.
My monitor's on my lap, guys.
The number one's gonna be big.
Do I...
Do I wanna...
Wait, do I have to roll an eight?
You have to roll a six.
I'm gonna roll an eight, everybody.
Watch this.
You wanna roll a one.
I'm going to roll an eight now.
I promise.
Stop.
Okay, how does this work?
The more...
But the thing is, the more stars she has, the more likely she'll get her stars stolen.
Don't.
Hi.
What's up, guys?
I hate to break it to you, but...
Like, I'm a little bit rich.
Let me just flex with, um...
Ooh, okay.
Yeah, mushroom tickets.
Yeah.
That looks good.
Um, chain chomp.
Move a star?
Please, up the toothpaste.
I don't give a frick.
I'm gonna...
Buy nothing.
I'm broke.
Okay.
A boo!
Wait, so...
How the fuck do you have 50 coins?
La boo boo.
What the fuck?
Cause I have a 24 karat golden la boo boo and you don't...
Is anyone actually own a la boo boo here?
There's only one and you don't own it.
If you're a broke boy, just say so.
I thought about getting one.
A la boo boo.
You should get a la boo boo.
I thought about getting a la boo boo too.
Then I remember, I hated it.
They're ugly.
What do you mean?
That's really rude of you.
They're ugly.
Fillian, you're rude.
Would you hate your child if they're ugly?
Yeah.
I literally went to a gas station.
Okay.
And they have them as well.
Isn't that how orphans came to be?
What, cause they're ugly?
Wait, so if you find out someone's an orphan on the internet, you can just call them ugly.
Damn.
Okay, that's not what I meant.
It's a freak crit.
That's not very nice.
This is war.
This is minigame.
Ooh.
Well.
No, don't take me.
This is one burn time.
Noo.
I'm gonna wager zero dollars.
Cause I'm rich.
You don't get to choose.
Seven.
Uh-oh.
Give me your money, guys.
No!
28 coins on the line.
Let's do this.
Oh, trampoline, I'm on one.
You're on a trampoline?
Yeah.
Can I come over?
Yes.
I want to play.
Whatever you want, we can do it.
Yes.
Oh, not this.
Okay, let's just go.
Let's just go.
Just go, just play, just play.
We all have the same idea.
Sop.
By the way, guys.
Here's someone.
That's winning because nobody is doing anything.
You effing quickie!
Quick you!
Now that's my shit.
Hold up.
That's my shit.
I like how nobody is that bothering Zen.
Nobody ever expects the toaster.
It's cool.
Yeah!
Thank you for the coins.
I lost coins.
It's because you stole my freaking star!
The rich isn't getting rich!
You stole my freaking star!
I was right behind you and I was begging.
I said no, please.
That is the most Twitter logic I've ever seen.
It was my star!
The stars didn't know you, bro!
No!
Oh!
You can steal an item from...
You can steal an item from Fillion.
No!
It's too me!
Then, it was too me.
I couldn't.
You're weak.
She's pitying me.
Not yet anyway.
I have a 24 card.
Instead, gonna go ahead and do this.
Oh!
No!
Brother, are you...
Please!
What did I...
No, okay.
Okay, so, hey, okay.
So...
Yeah, she's the rich...
Second richest.
Yeah, she's rich.
I love you.
Zen, have I ever said that...
Fillion has been...
Have I ever said that you are...
Beautiful and...
So kind and...
And she has the most money.
And you know...
You motherfucker.
I didn't sing her star!
And I just want to know her on Twitter!
Rate the Twitter for you.
Yay!
Yippee!
Stop being a baby!
What?
I'm getting modded by my own people!
Can I have your money?
Oh, oh.
Thank you.
That's how it happens.
It's always the people you most...
No!
You expect the most.
Damn, that's a lot.
Oh my God, Seth.
You know...
Oh my God.
It usually takes like 12.
Jesus.
You know, you could have swatted the booze away, right, Fillion?
Were you not pressing?
Oh, could I play this game before?
I thought you said you played these games before.
Yeah, you said that.
That's what you told me.
Mamma mia.
Wait.
Have you even seen Squid Game?
Question mark.
What in the world?
Of course.
Oh, I'm sure it's just coins.
Yay!
You're so rich now.
Oh my God, she's got 69 coins, bro.
She's got the entire US GDP in her pocket.
Nice.
What do I...
You guys are so far ahead.
Can you wait for me?
The star might show up near you, Mari.
How do I own?
Um...
I...
Will go...
And...
I'm just gonna try to roll really high.
Okay.
That's more than one.
Yeah.
So it's technically high.
It's technically very high.
It's double...
Oh, it's double than your last roll.
Wait.
That's big, though.
Maybe.
Let's see.
Two items.
See.
That makes it up.
Oh, sorry.
Nothing.
Oh, you got the shot?
Wait.
That's it?
Oh, okay.
Oh, triple dice!
Triple dice!
That's okay.
Yeah.
That's more than two.
Lucky me.
You can get more than two now.
Mini game!
Yay.
In the next round, I can use my triple dice and I can roll three.
What's the difference?
What'd it do?
If you roll a three, I'm giving you a 100 subs with those three dices.
Really?
Well, that might be worth it.
Wait, what?
What am I doing?
Ooh.
Wait, I didn't...
Oh!
You gotta get the difference or...
Okay.
Oh.
What?
I was impressed with the wrong one.
Just like this.
Which way do you hold the Wiimote?
What?
Wait, wait.
Which way do you hold the Wiimote?
What does this do?
You're holding a Wiimote?
Wait, so who picked the right one?
Does one pick the right one at the same time as me?
What?
No.
Am I stupid?
You gotta wait till you see the whole picture.
Yeah, wait, yeah.
Oh.
Technically.
I mean, you don't have...
Oops.
What?
Oh.
Oh, the odd one out!
Oh!
Like that.
Yeah.
Understood.
There you go.
Yeah.
The auto went out.
Okay, here we go.
Start.
Who skipped my cutscene?
I did.
Lock in.
You don't wanna see it.
Come on.
Bananas.
Grape!
I'm a player.
Those are the fastest.
Dang.
Damn.
Centrae is so fast.
I got last.
Round two.
Okay.
Here we go.
Lock it in.
Come on.
Okay.
I'm...
I'm going for this one.
Hey!
Stop edging!
That is some serious edging.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
That's awful.
I gambled.
I gambled it all.
If I gambled all...
So wait, it's the odd one out, right?
Yeah.
It's whichever one that's just by itself.
Guys, I think that's a banana.
Oh.
This is gonna be numbered.
Oh, I think I knew that.
Oh.
I'm a genius.
Am I old?
Oh my god.
Oh.
She's locked the fuck in.
Yeah.
I'm a failure.
Holy.
I already forgot.
That's what my dad said.
I already forgot what they look like.
Wait, is my stupid...
This one...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my...
I died!
I clicked the right one!
I forgot to me.
I figured the other one!
Oh my god.
I might be a bot.
Let's fucking go.
I'm a bot.
I'm a player.
Oh my god, stop.
Absolute suffering.
Wait, what was it?
No, you're having fun.
I'm walking in.
Wait.
I put the wrong button.
I think I got...
Oh, at least I got...
Oh, yeah!
I got third!
Let's go!
At least I'm third.
Not last.
Yes.
Did I get last place?
How do I know?
You'll know.
Yeah, definitely get first.
I'll tell you that one.
I love gambling.
Yay!
What you crying about?
You have a star.
You're a star.
Aw, thank you.
You do?
What the fuck?
Yes, she has a star!
No, I don't!
She stole it from me!
Stop!
Grow up, Cillian!
How about you...
Get taller!
I'm stealing your fucking spell.
How about you...
Just shut your mouth...
Oh, yeah!
Well, I'm gonna steal fucking...
Ladies, ladies...
Let's fight...
Oh, shit.
To live.
That's what I thought.
Okay.
Die spot.
The lady...
In the meantime, can you tell your mom to cook us some hot pockets?
Yeah.
Thanks.
I want a pizza.
You like that?
That shit's good.
Oh, yeah.
Big time.
And the bologna sandwich.
Oh, my God.
Double digits.
Oh.
Wow.
Oh, thank God.
We hit the Bowser block.
That's not fair.
Bye, train.
Oh, train.
Bye.
Oh, no.
Can I get the board in?
Fuck.
That's right.
Now you're even further from the star.
One day.
Don't worry.
Not today.
No.
Let's see.
Maybe he could go to a shop.
Actually, I do this.
Yeah.
It'd be.
Oh.
It'd be like.
Run around the entire planet.
Wow.
Amazing.
Use an item and somehow you're still in front of me.
What was the highest number you rolled, Mari?
Okay.
Of five, I think.
Wait.
That's pretty big.
You have 72 points.
Is that enough for you?
I was gonna say, Zen, you have 72 coins.
I think you'd be fine spending just a little bit more.
I am fine.
Might do a silly here.
Would you get richer?
Chad, am I winning?
If nobody gets the train.
I won't hit the train.
I know what you're doing.
Cookie.
No.
Okay.
I understand your game.
I can do a roger.
What?
I really haven't made these games before.
I hope you get three ones.
Nine.
Oh my god.
Nine, nine, nine?
Oh.
Ten dollars.
Holy shit.
Let's go.
She stored all her luck there now.
I've never seen somebody get that big of a number.
Yeah.
She actually stored all...
Jesus Christ.
You should get the chomp chomp.
Whistle.
Oh...
Um...
I want...
I wanna...
Yeah, chomp call is good.
Yeah, the chomp call is good.
How do I hear you?
Yeah.
I wanna do hair hair.
You have to be wild, Luigi.
Everyone is so jealous of my huge, disgusting numbers.
Oh yeah.
Wait, did you just...
Oh.
Huh?
Uh...
Wait, is that gonna steal your money to go right?
No.
She has to land...
Add it specifically.
Oh...
So it's useless.
Wait, I need a...
Do I need a key?
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Yes.
I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I don't even have a key.
Wait.
I can still reach the star.
You do have enough numbers, though.
Yeah, you have enough for the star.
Yes.
Brother, leave my point alone.
Not it.
I'm gonna steal.
Okay, not it.
If you steal Fillion's money, she won't have enough for the star.
No, Ebuz, I have 19 coins.
The second star!
Zed has 72 bucks!
Yeah, but Fillion won't have enough to buy a second star.
I didn't have a star.
You steal her money.
Yeah.
Fillion, you have a star, so I need to steal your money.
Yo, you guys, you guys use anything for an excuse.
This is a crazy one.
Well, you're in first place.
That is an excuse.
Why do I always get bronze with a brawl?
You better stop pressing.
I gotta start messing with it.
Yeah, you push it really fast.
Press.
Click.
I'm in.
Fast.
Correct!
And when I say fast, like really fast.
Nice.
Yeah.
That was pretty good.
That was a good steal.
I would have preferred to have 17 coins though.
Wario!
Yes!
What does he get for the ally?
It's an ally minigame.
Oh, we all have to fight for it.
We all fight for him.
We have fighting for his big ass.
But since I met him first, he gives me the advantage.
Yeah.
Guys, we can't let her get her.
She'll get two stars.
Yeah.
But it would be nice.
Cause Mario's a lot of spam.
It must be everyone with Mario party.
The fuck is this one?
Oh, it's a...
Oh, no.
Quiz show.
Wait, what?
What is this?
I'm a genius.
What?
What is this?
Oh, like which one's different?
Yeah.
Oh.
It's like that last one.
It's all just game show games.
Wait, what?
There's different games?
Yeah.
Ready up.
Okay.
Oh, man.
Let's go.
Oh, this is complicated.
Hi, Wario.
I am... I love him.
Look at that ass.
He's huge.
Yeah.
Start.
Round one.
What?
Oh.
I won.
Fuck.
Jack, you should be looking at my controller.
Round two.
This is just... Oh, it's like WarioWare.
What's happening?
What?
You have to pick the longest.
Oh, yeah.
Wow.
Round three.
Jesus.
Nah.
Oh, it's this one.
We did this one.
Mari is on fire.
Yay.
How did you get that so fast?
Aw.
He was holding hands.
Oh.
How many coins is there?
Like 18.
Oh.
I failed.
I pressed the wrong one.
I might have drawn.
Yay.
Wait, I did that.
I thought I was 11.
It's hard to count.
Fuck math.
Oh, my lord.
Oh, no shit.
Aw.
Is that it?
Wait, is it filling in my dead end?
Jesus.
Double points.
I'm back, baby.
Oh, double points is where it's at.
What the hell?
Wait, did I win?
Am I so fucking happy?
I got three fucking points.
How many more rounds?
Five more?
Where will he stop?
How do I get a no-world guy stop?
Goddamn.
I'm a failure.
Well, how did you click so fast?
It's double points, too.
Oh, damn.
Wait.
I might be able to come back.
Oh, my God.
It was so fast.
She's doing it.
She's aiming.
Oh, my God.
She's locking in now.
Fillion, stop.
There's three more rounds.
I did this.
You're in the first.
Oh.
Ah.
I was trying to click not eight.
Oh.
Oh, yes.
It's eight.
Oh, no.
I pressed the wrong button.
I counted wrong again.
Fillion, stop.
I'm stupid.
Why don't you just...
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
Fuuuuck.
What is the wrong button?
No, it's the wrong button.
Wait.
We all got it wrong.
I got peer-pression.
We might have peer-pression.
I heard the sound.
I was like, okay.
Yes.
Isn't it right, so...
Oh.
Holy shit.
Oh, shit.
Wait, did I win?
Yes.
Oh!
Yeah!
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
It's okay, you guys can steal my money again.
It's fine.
You can steal my money.
Alright.
The key...
Yeah, the key is to make sure she has no money to get any stars.
That's the key.
I hope you get more stolen from you than just your money, Fillion.
Whoa.
Like in Minecraft, right?
Bro, I got a bestie.
No, in Mario Party.
What?
Wait, so don't anyone pass me?
Wait, they're gonna steal my boy?
I hope you enjoy him.
What do you do?
Yeah, as long as someone passes you, you lose Wario.
Like, he's not... he's not loyal.
Okay.
I'm gonna land on a Bowser space?
Yeah.
We're stealing your boy.
Ah, fuck it.
I don't car.
What's happening?
I'm gonna land on a Bowser.
I'm buying a star.
There's no loser star on that Bowser.
You got a star.
Ah.
I could have got two stars if I had Wario.
And hopefully, we'd land on it.
I have to.
My chat's writing fanfics with Wario already.
Where's the next star?
Look, it's right in front of me.
Wait, it is.
Wait, what?
That's a lot of people's dreams.
That's not even randomized.
Oh my god, she can nearly buy a second star.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That'd be crazy.
Holy shit.
Lucky me.
Well, you got your two stars.
Yay.
Shit.
Then it's time to go to the booze cap.
It's time to go to the booze cave.
I'm gonna land on the bowser space.
It might get stolen anyway.
She just asked him for the novel.
Wait, who's in front of this star?
Hey, it's for me.
Lucky.
Steamer ticket.
You're broke.
Oh, you don't get it.
You don't get it.
Oh, wait.
You miscounted.
Holy shit.
Nice.
Oh, because of the stars thing.
Yahoo!
No way.
Lucky, lucky.
Lucky.
And a hidden block?
Okay, it's not a star.
Thank God.
I wanna know.
Lucky, lucky, lucky.
Lucky, lucky.
Mini game.
Well, you got Wario fillion, so it's okay.
Oh, I got Wario.
You got two stars!
We're on the same team.
You have to lock in.
Two axes taxis.
I'm going to sandbag you.
Zen, this might not be my day, Zen.
Got you.
Don't worry.
What is this?
What do we do?
I go side to side.
I go forward.
You go up and down.
Oh.
What?
Am I controlling this car?
You're controlling side to side movement, and I'm controlling the down movement.
Yep.
There you go.
Wait, am I doing this?
We got this.
How do we turn?
Oh.
With you!
Oh, I gotta hold it!
Oh!
Nice.
We can't do it at the same time.
I noticed that.
Oh!
Alright, let's get it.
She's really good at this.
Go.
You better...
Alright.
You better lock in.
I can only do well during the practice.
I'm going to kill you.
Practice.
What?
I'm going to make us lose, Mari.
No!
We can do this if we just...
I'm going to make us lose.
This is what you deserve.
That's...
Stop!
Go!
Let go!
Let go forward!
Okay.
Turn!
It's up to you.
You turn, bro!
And then I'll go.
Still going.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Go.
Yes!
Come on, come on.
We're in the way, we're in the way.
No!
Keep going!
We have to wait!
Wait for it!
Stop!
Nice, nice, nice!
Oh, wait.
Bro!
You.
I'm going to go!
Yo.
You're mom!
You, you, you.
It's going on!
Nice line.
It's a cock!
Go!
More, more, more!
Down!
Yes!
Up!
Wow!
Hut!
Two, three, four!
It's okay.
Go to RNG and we're back.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh, good stuff.
Oh, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running!
Yay!
Okay, I actually locked in.
Holy shit.
I actually locked in for that, just for you, Zen.
It's because Villian threw.
It was teamwork makes the dream work.
I could see that.
The vision is real.
Nah, I have enough for a star.
My teammate threw.
I should get compensation.
I'm sorry.
You guys joined the entire game.
And then when I crashed out, it's my fault.
Am I the bad guy?
What is this guy doing?
Don't touch me.
How come you're locked in whenever you're by yourself, but you don't lock in for Mario?
That's fucked up.
Is he my sugar daddy?
Damn.
I think you're...
I mean, sort of.
It's Renowario.
You're living a lot of people's dreams right now.
One.
You're living my dream.
Yeah, one of Wario's the man from you.
I mean, he's got the booty.
Whoa!
It's true.
Wait, what's happening?
I got two?
You get two, because Wario gives you two.
Dang, Wario OP!
Oh god!
My man, okay!
Yeah, because you have friends now.
Yeah!
Oh my god, it's gonna be so long until I get anywhere.
Goodbye Bowser, blah.
Still not too bad.
No worries.
Maybe eventually something will show up in front of me.
This is gonna be crazy.
I know how to cheer everybody up.
By getting a star!
Well, some people anyway.
Are you gonna steal?
No.
Wait, what are you gonna do?
What's happening?
What are you doing?
To where?
Something really fucked up.
What are you doing?
Stop!
What?
Am I in danger?
Zen!
Let's talk about it, okay?
Like, okay, I'm not in the lead anymore.
Mariah has two stars.
50 gifted subs to Zen from Filian if you...
If you wasn't.
You guys have e-boyed me long enough.
You guys are...
Twitter begging right now.
Like, come on.
Zen, don't do this.
Filian, I don't know what...
Eh?
Who's at that?
Yeah, you get more.
I wonder who she'll choose.
Filian!
She's gonna do something really funny.
Zen, you have to...
I'm gonna sit here right now, okay?
You either do the really funny...
Or you show your true colors.
Wait, no.
You show...
You...
Have I ever told you?
I really...
Think you can...
I can...
You're...
Wow.
She doesn't even have...
She can't even think of one good thing to say to you.
Um...
That's a...
I can't even think of one good compliment.
I love this lab.
Yeah, you're a neuro.
I think you're really cool.
And I like that we got a Bondo for Pokemon cards so soon.
And I think you're really witty and funny.
And I hope that...
We can...
Be...
Closer friends after this.
That's so fucked up.
That Filian can't even say one thing.
I think...
When your TTS doesn't win...
It's pretty...
It's content.
And also, Filian called you a slur.
No!
True!
She...
She called us...
She said a slur!
True!
Hey, hey, Doki!
And she didn't get a pass for it too!
Hey, Doki!
I already got it for that one.
I can't use it again.
She said it twice.
Yeah, she didn't get the pass.
How about I do something super fair?
No.
It's Mario Party.
There's no such thing as fair.
It's Mario Party!
You can't steal my star.
Every time I play with...
Yes, Vivian.
That's rude.
Legal government statement.
Make a poll in your chat.
No.
And see who I should steal the star from.
Yeah, Filian.
That's a really good idea, but sadly...
There's zero viewers right now, so...
Oh, you know what's so awesome?
I'm a moderator in Filian's chat, so I can make a poll.
That's really interesting!
Yeah.
That's really interesting.
I can make a poll right now, so I'll go in Filian's chat and I'll make a poll.
Get out of my...
By all means.
See, guys?
Look, having zero stars is a good thing sometimes.
Just so we can get an unbiased opinion.
Yeah.
So, like...
Okay, Zen, so...
You know, like...
Like, you called me Vivian and, like, I thought that was okay.
You know, we can grow past, like, our mistakes.
And, um...
What is...
I voted?
Brother, this is not the presidential election.
Nice poll!
What does the poll say?
I can't read it.
I can't read the poll.
I'm biased.
It says Filian.
Wow.
Who would've...
The game was rigged since the start.
I know.
It looks like...
A thousand people...
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, yay.
Don't blame me.
Blame democracy in the chat.
I'm a tree!
Don't they say, like, chat reflects the streamer?
I hate Mario Party!
I never wanna play this game again!
Every time I hate my doggy bird, she's like, what?
Let's gang up on Filian.
And I never wanna play...
That's not true!
When did I do that?
I like the funny reaction!
Oh, the funny reaction!
It's okay, Filian.
Chat!
Clip that!
I think Chat maybe just wants you to lose the game.
Done.
Filian...
What did I do?
I have zero stars!
Do you need your binky?
Do you need your rattle?
Hey, Mari!
What?
Love yourself.
Now.
I do!
Thank you very much.
Great, I just have to be sure.
I care about you.
Keep yourself safe.
I care about you too.
I love you, say it back.
I'm not gay.
She didn't say it back.
Damn.
That's rough, buddy.
It's fine, I'm used to Filian being mean to me.
It's alright.
Just roll!
Oh, are you a masochist?
Where everything is so fucked up here.
Shy.
Just roll!
I'm figuring out what I wanna do.
Oh, you take the...
Oh, you should get the...
Both of your stars!
The...
Yes.
The chop...
Yeah, I was gonna say, the chop hop.
If it's any consolation, I think you're gonna win the game.
Uh...
Oh, really?
Can you explain how in, uh, under ten words?
Pure luck.
This Mario Party is never fair.
The heart of the cards, baby.
Yay.
I put like half the minigames, bro.
I don't have any money.
Wait, what's the blue thing?
The blue door.
The mirror, it swaps places with another person.
That could be good.
That same skill.
Chance time.
Wait, why would I step on that?
You can get coins.
You can get coins from people.
So true.
Remember that thing where I said about luck?
Yeah.
No, wait, watch.
I have control.
This is it.
Wait, really?
What is it?
Is it a star?
You might be able to get two stars back.
Yeah.
That's how I lost the game.
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
No.
Wait.
Who wants my 10?
Can I help them, please?
Can I have coins?
Yes, you can.
Oh, my God.
You gave me 10 coins.
Thank you.
This is where it all starts.
Bro, this is my comeback story.
I filed for bankruptcy and then I get a loan of a bill.
I told you.
Thank you.
You know what, Zed?
You will believe me when no one else did.
I fucking told you.
You're my day one, bro.
You're my real one, okay?
Didn't she just steal your star?
Yeah, didn't she steal your star?
Isn't that even worse?
Don't.
Hey.
Something like that.
You want to say that.
I literally gave you money, and you're like, Zed, you're the real one.
Yeah, I just gave you 10 coins.
What the hell?
All right.
I'm ready.
Mama Mia.
All right, chat.
You ready for this?
They call this...
Who can match fast?
God, I need one of those, like, things that, like, constantly does stuff.
I hate mashing!
I'm so good at mashing!
I'm still bad at mashing.
But who are you talking to?
That's not me too.
Holy shit.
Chat, I might not be a woman.
Fuck.
Oh, frick.
Do they have my hands feel tired?
Oh, never mind, it doesn't.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I feel so slow today, though.
Jesus.
You've been practicing.
I'm the worst masher.
My reaction time is very slow today, though, today.
For sure.
Maybe you don't jerk it enough.
Oh.
Yeah, see, chat?
I'm not a goer.
See?
You know what?
I take that W.
You're bad at masters.
You're bad with your fingers.
I've got money.
Yeah, that's why I'm single.
Homestretch.
Wait, how many turns?
Wait, was this only ten turns?
Wait a second.
Aren't you just with Wario?
I'm gonna get adopted?
Guys, I think I'm in first place.
What is this?
It's homestretch.
I wanna go home.
Oh, they gave you a little bonus.
Oh, I can pick an event?
Can I, um...
Can I get more stars?
Oh, do Bowser spaces.
That'll make it more fun.
Okay.
That is true.
Oh.
Yay.
Well, this got worse.
I like AIDS.
Nice.
Okay, so what happened when you went on a Bowser square?
You died.
Trying to find out.
You fucking die.
Jesus Christ.
It's okay.
It doesn't have stars, so it won't affect her as much.
Yeah, well, you don't have...
A brain.
I don't know.
I just tricked.
I'm so bored.
Are you guys gonna steal Wario from me?
Millian, Wario is leaving in one turn.
Yeah, you got it.
I don't care.
What?
You got him and you didn't do anything with him.
Why am I supposed to go with him?
Oh, Millian.
You could have used your double block.
If you used your double block, you could have got two stars, Millian.
Don't even call him.
I don't think I'm gonna make it the star.
Yeah, I knew it.
Don't know.
I knew.
I was not.
I'm not lucky today.
Oh.
Hey.
Whoa.
Let's fight.
Fight.
All of them.
You're right.
This is the most.
I have nothing to lose.
You took my man, Doki.
Wait, I don't even have him.
Fight.
Yeah, you literally stole him.
I have nothing to lose.
I'm fucking broke.
All the marbles.
Wait, what?
Oh.
This stupid one.
This one is really funny.
You can punch each other.
Yeah.
Stop punching.
Marbles on screen.
Oh my god.
Worldstar.
That's right.
Let's fucking fight.
Get out of here.
Worldstar attack.
Can you fight?
Yeah.
Alright, I figured it out.
Alright, you gotta run straight and throw hands.
Adios.
Okay.
Billion.
What?
You take...
Wait, which side are you taking?
What do you mean?
No.
Which side are you taking?
We're gonna bet...
I bet $100 that Zentreya's gonna win.
I bet $100,000 she's gonna win.
So you owe me $999,000.
Yeah, i punched you out!
I guessed.
It doesn't work like that.
Bro, punching was useless.
I said it first.
PUNCHING was useless.
I was trying to punch her out of here.
I didn't realize it.
I just wanted to fight.
Worldstar.
You could be as smart at Zrender for this world.
That's a rare opportunity.
Oh, hey!
Shut up, are you serious?
Today's just not my day.
Can somebody give me coins?
Wait, do you get... I need coins.
Oh, she gets Wario too.
No.
What does that do?
You can take my shot, too.
Oh.
Wait, what is that?
Is that bad?
No, she gets to steal your stuff.
Brother, I have nothing!
What?!
That is just really unfortunate.
Zen, I'm already naked.
Like, what else do you want?
I'm sorry.
You've taken everything from me.
Just don't hit her one.
Okay.
Oh my god, and she gets the double stuff.
Oh wait, she doesn't.
She's not a one.
She gets another star.
Wait, you're winning!
Shout out my codes.
Who's closest to 50 dollars?
None of us.
You got a star!
You're a star.
She's rich gets richer.
No wonder Zen suggested Mario Party.
Forgot the might of the entire world against me.
What else to do?
Of course she suggested it.
It seems we've been set up.
Seems we've been set up to make her look good.
I would never.
This is the same type of vibe when you're first asked for karaoke and you know they're cracked at it.
I shouldn't.
Yeah, I shouldn't have fixed my game capture.
What if I... I just have gotten my ass beats continuously.
End this game.
How many jamborees have you played?
Don't ask.
Oh my god.
We could look at our pro... I'm looking at our profile.
I'm getting close.
I'm looking.
Yeah, check her stats.
Check her stats.
I'm checking her stats right now.
He's on PEDs.
Alright, I'm looking at her stats right now.
Alright, friends.
Oh wait, you can look.
Yeah.
You can look after the game too because you get like a Mario Party star.
You played... You played 60 hours of Mario Party?
Wait, how many hours have I played?
All that just to lose to me.
Wait, how many... You have 20 hours.
Kill 60?
Yeah, yeah.
Zen has fucking 60.
Wait, I don't have any fucking coins!
Zen has 60 hours.
Wait, how many hours do I have?
I have four hours.
How many do I have?
You have... You have played for a little while, which means this is your first game.
Are we about to fight for two coins?
Fight for a little while.
I can only wager two.
No fuck, you have one there.
Two whole ass coins.
I have four hours on this game.
Breaking the bank.
Yo.
I'm gonna wager everything.
Okay, so I need to take this really seriously.
Okay, good job, Mario.
You got it.
She's trying to take your... If you let Zen win, she'll get the minigame.
Yeah.
Minigame star.
Give me your lunch money.
Wait, you're loving one of me for two bucks?
Let's go!
Oh, for... It's all I have.
What's this?
Oh.
Move up and down?
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Ow.
You get bumped down and you get hit.
I bet.
Let's get it.
Alright, Marthy.
Okay.
You ready for this?
You are against a real gamer.
You are against a real gamer right now.
Damn, four whole coins.
But I love Mario.
So... Guys, you guys gotta get through the first part.
The first thing.
Brother!
Go, go, go!
I'm through, I'm through, I'm through.
They see me, I'm up.
Oh, the risk.
Mother...
Risk it all.
Dude, there's too much friction.
Wow.
Ow.
Okay.
I'm higher.
I can see Billy and Brute forcing it.
No, I'm not.
Two whole fucking coins.
I got your two coins.
The most intense game I've ever seen.
I got your coins.
Yippee.
You took my... I mean, she was never gonna play this game again.
You took my last dollar.
Bro, you have, like, $40.
And you can't refund a game within two hours, dude.
Who took my last dollar?
And now I'm gonna stop.
Bro, it's Nintendo.
You probably can't refund it anyway.
Yeah, that's exactly.
Mini game time.
No, refund it.
We need to play again on another day to see.
And we need to figure out who's a bitch.
We need to get 60 hours, like Zen.
We need to play Monopoly next time.
Come on, guys.
Monopoly.
Yeah, that game's way cooler.
I hate Monopoly.
All right, all right.
You guys are haters.
It's fine.
Oh, I jumped.
Oh, they have a lot of version on Steam, I found.
Bro, so why are we not looking at the stars?
We're looking at the rock.
Oh, we can, like, body block each other.
Just as I said that.
I'm falling apart.
I'm so sorry.
Don't let me die.
Don't let us die, guys.
We're all friends.
Why can't we be friends?
It's okay, the comebacks are gonna go crazy.
We don't have any time for a comeback.
Yes, we do.
Friendship.
Yay!
So much friendship.
We're so close.
Wow, look it, we have no personal space.
At all.
Don't need stars.
What is personal space, Zen?
That world's really big.
Yay!
Wow.
Holy frick.
Wait, there's only two turns left?
Yeah.
Zen selected ten turns.
It's over.
I'm too tilted.
Oh.
Shit.
My bad.
Philly and those bonus stars, though.
Yeah, for what?
Getting gangbang?
Like...
Why would you say that?
Actually, yes.
Wait.
Wait, really?
Isn't there a star more of the most red spaces landed on?
Hi, Mario.
Mario.
Technically.
Wait.
Wait, there's a star for Misfortune?
Yeah.
Holy frick.
No, I'm pretty sure.
We're back.
I don't know what this thing does.
I'm using it.
What's that thing get it?
Well, sometimes there's a star for Misfortune.
She's believing.
There's a star for minigames, Misfortune, and...
Watch this.
Ten!
Luckiest.
Is there still a sticker stock?
Yeah, there is.
Awesome.
Ooh, land on the Bowser's face.
Oh, if I go forward, I can get a Bowser.
If I go south, I can get an item.
I believe.
Bowser is.
Why would I feel bad for you and give you money?
Oh, that's true.
If you're broke, you can get money.
Can I 1v1 someone for both of their stars?
Not in particular, of course.
Huh?
What is it?
Pair up the item you want?
Talk too fast.
What did you say?
You got this.
He wants the 1v1 to get stars.
Oh.
What am I doing?
I only memorized, like, two items, so I'm just gonna have to...
I only memorized this, so I'm just gonna do that.
Okay.
I mean, that's the best one.
That's a good item.
It is?
That's the best item there.
Yeah, it's three dice blocks.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, that's the only one I memorized.
Let's have me get it.
Okay.
Wait, so, can you guys steal that?
You guys would never, right?
We can steal anything we want.
I won't.
I promise.
Thank you.
Wait, where is the...
next star?
How do we?
How do we get that?
Oh!
Congrats!
That's how we get it.
I moved it.
Okay.
You did it!
Yeah, you did.
Yes.
Yes!
What you did there?
I'm going back home, guys.
Wait, why are you over there now?
Okay, not here.
I...
What?
There's a shop here?
Wait, you...
Did you lose money?
No, no, I get...
I get closer to the...
Oh!
Wow!
Yeah.
Wait, that's a wooden group.
She's a genius.
He's got a hole where his nuts are.
I'm gonna grab this.
What?
The Goomba.
There's a wooden Goomba with a door.
What?
The door where his nuts are?
Yes!
Where?
In the background?
It's like in the above Doki, you know what I'm saying?
If I can't win, I'll just creep.
Yeah, you see?
Look at that.
Freak you out, Goomba.
You saw that jump?
Oh, hey.
That's a female, Goomba.
That's just his...
Oh.
Oh, right.
Hussein.
Where's the most money?
Not it.
Okay, so...
No, brother.
I...
Yes, I...
You are my...
Abba.
You...
You are a tower defense unit that exists to bully me!
What do you mean?
I literally said who I was just taking was the most money.
Oh, I got a match!
Shouldn't have been rich, I guess.
No!
Shouldn't have been rich.
Yay, money!
I want money!
Yeah.
We are want money.
This economy is fucking rough.
Sigh.
Yay!
100 coins sure would be nice right now.
Yeah, it would be pretty.
Cool.
You should do the double dice, I might as well.
Let's get closer to the staff.
What is the ticket?
You can do something.
Um, it's plus five.
That is true.
I see why Thillion doesn't do multiplayer games much, LaMal.
It hurts.
I understand your pain.
Ted!
Now you're ten blocks closer.
Can you come down here with me?
Let's hang out.
Let's see.
You might be able to take the train and get closer to the star.
Aww.
I'll miss you.
Fair enough.
I'll come back.
Don't worry.
I'll catch up.
Go away.
Oh, you just left.
You really just said I'll come back and you got on the train.
What?
I mean, she could come back still.
Whoa.
Who stops?
I'm coming back.
Ah!
Sneakle core.
Oh, where did I go?
Oh my god, that was a hit and run!
Wait, are you actually right behind me?
Haha, wait!
That's gonna actually get tough!
Told you.
Can you 1v1 me?
I gotta hit and run!
Did anyone get the license plate?
Okay.
How does it work?
Oh.
Just drop it.
Okay.
I need it.
It's pretty easy.
You have to say Plinko after it lands.
Plinko.
Oh!
What did the Maddie mirror do?
Plinko!
It lets you trade spots with people.
Oh.
You got an item.
Yeah, whoever's closest is a star.
You can trade with them.
Pickle?
Wait.
Chat, where is the next star at?
Pickle Rig.
I don't think anyone knows right now.
That's the funniest shit I've ever heard.
You gotta have a high IQ to understand that joke.
Where's the star?
Pickle Rig!
Yeah, my entire chat just spammed Pickle Rig now.
Uh...
You have a very smart chat.
You're triggering the hive mind.
That makes sense.
Yeah, chat, we're smart, right?
Where did I wanna go?
Mai, where's the star?
Um, it's behind us.
It's right here.
Congrats.
It's behind you?
It's behind both of us, bro.
Wow!
Call one player over for 10 coins.
Ooh, I want coins.
Wait, no.
Doesn't it cost you 10 coins?
Wait a sec.
Don't.
Is it a good idea?
Call everybody.
Yes.
Yay!
Let's all have a party!
Let's call everybody in one spot!
No.
Wait, you took the train, you could have got first here.
Wait, maybe that could have been smarter idea.
Let's get some drinks.
Yay!
Break time.
The milk saloon.
Invite one.
What does that do?
What happened?
Oh, it invites somebody randomly.
No!
I wanna choose!
Can you invite me to your Xbox?
Who do you pick?
Come on over.
Oh!
You brought Zen over!
Hi!
Hi Zen!
I told you.
You walked the whole round.
You need the light off the middle.
Bro, she walked like 10 spaces.
She's tired.
Let her have some rest.
Sorry.
Had too much.
Oh my god, it's like a date.
That's the good stuff.
Wait, what?
What happened?
You just brought her over.
What?
You just made me waste 10 coins!
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a date.
Well, did you have a good time?
You for the free drink.
Oh, it's money.
I feel like you should've paid because you make more than me.
Walk and check.
What do I do?
Oh, it's just...
You'll get me next time though, right?
Oh, I'm running to a wall.
Yes.
I got you.
Thanks, buddy.
Well, this one at least can get your money back.
Yay.
Here we go.
I got gone so bad.
Everybody be cool.
Let's all share the coins.
I get it because we're on ice.
Yeah.
Be cool.
True.
Oh no.
That is so funny.
Stop.
I got hit.
You are a money stealer.
She does need the money.
Look, she's been through a lot.
Everybody be cool.
Look at the controls.
You be cool.
Chill.
Fuck.
My money.
What do you mean your money?
You stole mine.
We're rich.
I kept trying to steer left and right because of racing games.
I deserve that coin.
Where did I go?
I'll get you back.
Don't worry.
I owe you.
Ah, thanks.
Clip it and ship it, everybody.
Everybody wins.
Oh, three turns left, guys.
Don't fuck it up.
Wait, so where?
View board.
Yes, I like to do that.
Come on.
Fill me in.
Wait, the store's like 18 hours away from me.
What?
You could do the chop chop call.
Oh, you don't have it.
Big number.
Come on.
Yeah, I'm broke.
Wait, so if I buy a ticket, can I go down?
Wait.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
Wait, why not?
You have nothing to lose.
I can't see the map.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
I'm just going on the assumption.
You have nothing to lose.
Okay, here we go.
Maybe.
Big roll here.
It's winnable.
Big money.
Stop.
Grim, Grim.
Boom.
Oh, that's a goal.
Nice.
That's not enough.
I mean...
Yeah, not that lucky.
But you got a ticket.
So, how do I buy one ticket?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know where I'm going.
Wait, I think we're going on the train.
So, you can get a train.
You can get the train.
Yeah.
Okay.
And the train will take you...
It will take you anywhere you want.
Well...
Wait, don't hit me.
I thought it was.
Wait, did I kill you?
No.
I killed them?
What?
You know, you moved them closer to the star.
Did anybody get that number?
Wait.
One stop or two stops?
Where did this take me?
I think you...
How many stops?
I'm pretty sure you put them closer to the star now.
I don't know.
I'm going to do one stop.
We'll see what happens.
You go backwards or forward?
Wait, you can go backwards?
Yeah.
Forwards.
Wait, I...
Oh, okay, cool.
Yes.
That's where I want to go.
Okay?
I think this is going to the plan, right?
Fly to the left now.
Fly to the right.
Oh, you're closer to the star.
Yeah.
Oh, the math worked!
Oh, my frick.
Wait.
Okay.
It's winnable.
Alright, get me out of here.
Alright.
We're on our way.
No, she needs 18.
Wait, who's closest?
What is this?
Mushroom?
Super creepy.
Fillion is closest to the star.
Alright.
Mate, this is her comeback.
It's coming.
I'm gonna buy this.
What does it do?
Plus five.
Okay, I bought that.
Okay, sick.
Great.
Okay.
Go, Fillion, go!
How close is she?
I have to steal mine for myself.
Yes.
Oh.
What happens here if you land on your own?
I'm my only fan.
Oh, he called the train closer.
Oh.
Oh, never mind.
Yeah.
It's just a train moving.
I thought it was gonna hit you.
Wait, someone has a mirror!
Is someone gonna kill me?
Oh, no.
Uh...
Shirley's and Trey wouldn't swap places with you.
I worked so hard, Zen.
I spent 20 bucks to get there.
I would not.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait, what's happening?
The star is moving.
Are you serious?
It went closer?
Oh.
It is not my day.
Don't mirror me.
You're bribing the competition?
It's just not meant to be.
Not for...
Not Doki day.
All you have to do is ask nicely.
Do we have any friends?
And then I got you.
It's not a Doki day today.
Okay.
Thanks.
But I still can use it though.
Right?
Oh.
Sure.
So here's the thing.
Then we were a team.
You don't want me to be last days.
Since you said don't swap with you.
Yeah.
I'm not swapping with you.
Technically.
I thought I'm talking to Elle from Death Note.
You're gonna kill me aren't you?
But it's random.
Ohhhh.
I'm sorry.
But it's random.
Were you funny if you swapped with Mari?
Aww.
We were meant to be together.
That's pretty funny.
That's actually pretty funny.
Best friends forever.
So I'm getting places real fucking fast.
The only way is to make sure Fillion doesn't get...
Oh.
No.
Are you shitting me?
Huge.
One fucking move.
Mushroom.
Why does your shotgun sound like that?
I'm gonna get so high.
Because he's that guy.
He's that guy.
Nah.
You're not that bad.
I don't got any items.
I bet I'll roll a 10.
I was close.
You could get the...
Oh, I was gonna say... Wait, so when did Zentraya get three effing stars?
You could get the train, and then run over Fillion.
No, Fillion's out of the way of the train.
Yeah, it's over.
I'm in last place.
With you.
Yeah, but I don't wanna be last.
Wait, so you're telling me you're atop your A-F-A-F-A-F-A.
I don't wanna be last.
And you're playing not for first.
You're playing to not be last?
Yeah, not last.
It's been my thing for years, not last.
It's all about who I can make having a living hell.
As long as I'm not last, I'm happy.
Oh, I'm having a great time, don't worry about me.
Exactly.
One again, off again.
Wait, are we against Fillion?
Yeah, we are.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, I hate this game.
Oh, this one's gonna be funny.
I see.
Oh, I can kill you guys!
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Wow!
I'm so bad at this one.
Yeah, okay, I figured.
Die, die, die!
It's okay.
Carry.
I'm bad at it.
Alright, Mari, I believe in you, Mari.
I believe in you to carry us all.
I believe.
I told you, I know Mari can do it.
I just didn't wanna live anymore.
I feel like the less people on the screen, the easier it is too.
Oh shit!
Nevermind.
Let's go!
I thought I could do it.
But I jumped right on her.
That's the most happiest I've heard her all game.
That's because she hates me.
Yeah.
Mari, I died so you can clutch.
What happened?
I'm sorry, I got nervous.
My palms started sweating, my knees got weak, and my arms got heavy.
You're in the zone though.
But what about mom's spaghetti?
Right.
Well, that would make everything a little bit better.
Oh, hey!
Yoshi!
Hi, Yoshi!
Hello.
That guy.
Oh, you can see copy items.
He's so far away.
I don't think any of us can even get it.
No, I can't.
We only have two turns.
What does this do?
Here's your plus five.
That's plus tier dice roll.
Do it.
You have to do it to get your star.
Wait, where's the star?
Literally in front of you.
The yellow thing.
Right in front of you.
Oh, it's a yellow?
Oh, wait, there's no way I lose this.
Claim your star.
I claim.
It's what you deserve.
Jump up superstar.
I'm a man, I'm a man.
And you do do.
You're my double star.
I'm a man.
You didn't get a lot of buddies, Flo.
You got a star.
That is a beautiful song.
He's in an edit.
Who?
Yeah.
What?
Who was in an edit?
Yeah.
What kind of edit?
What do you mean he was in an edit?
I don't know.
Wait, that's next to us.
Oh, frick.
Where am I?
Give each other big kisses.
Cinema.
On the cheeks.
Okay, there's no way.
Cinema.
Chat.
Start hugging and kissing and touching.
Wait, how many?
Do I need?
Okay, I can just get...
Kiss a honey.
You know what?
I'll just grab nine.
Is this a mode?
Smile really big for me.
And look in the mirror and call yourself Freddy.
What mode is this?
Me and y'all.
Mods ban me and y'all.
Let's just get nine.
Is that more?
A little bit.
Just a little.
Don't go too crazy.
Mods ban me and y'all.
Yeah, I got a star too, guys.
I'm part of the team.
Everybody got a star.
Who's that a mode?
No, I'm part of the crew now.
Mods, jerk it a little.
Okay, I got a turn.
I got a turn.
Where's the next star?
Why is that your mode?
Me and y'all.
Wait, what is?
What is that?
I don't know.
It's like my entire...
It's like 17 frogs kissing in a weird like, yeah.
What?
I don't think we have it.
I don't know.
But I don't know which ones we have.
Don't judge.
Because, um...
We listen.
I only see text.
We don't judge.
Oh.
We listen, we don't judge.
Okay, who's going first?
Zen has an variant of it.
Yeah.
Is it worth it?
God damn it.
I forgot about mine.
Yeah!
Fuck it.
Freaky ass motherfuckers.
That's what I'm saying!
Freaky odd chat.
Are they kissing?
Sorry.
I forgot.
I can't judge.
Oh yeah.
We listen and we don't judge.
My bad.
No kink shaming.
Sorry.
One time...
When I was super tired...
I put a frozen pizza in the oven...
and I accidentally cooked it upside down...
and a bunch of the cheese started melting off...
onto the bottom of the oven.
Yay!
And when I took it out...
I didn't realize that it was upside down...
and then I cut into it...
and I said, this is a weird looking pizza...
and I went to bed without eating it...
and then when I woke up in the morning...
I realized that I cooked it upside down.
I feel like that's not tired...
That's gotta be like...
I like eating cold pizza.
We listen and we don't judge.
Okay, that's fair.
That just sounds like depression.
Sometimes...
We listen and we don't judge.
Help me.
Oh, you should...
Wait!
What?
Big number.
Big number!
Hey.
12.
Where will this take me?
Well, time to find out.
I don't think any of...
Yeah, none of us can reach the other star...
Unless you...
Uh...
Get a triple block.
No, you can't...
You can Chomp Chomp call it...
and hope for the best.
I like this.
Look, a horse!
Oh, versus!
Oh, again.
Oh, you get one last item.
So many items.
Somebody admit something embarrassing so I don't feel so alone.
Yeah.
I microwave a salad.
I spread my peanuts?
Oh, true.
What?
Oh, yours is much worse to keep going.
Yeah, wait, wait.
Wait, you microwave a salad?
Don't worry about it.
Wait, like, what was the mindset for that?
Charity goal.
Oh.
Fucking nasty.
You ate it?
Wait, did you eat it?
I'm so sorry I interrupted you.
Fillion, please continue.
No!
What about your peanuts?
Uh...
Sometimes I microwave food and I forget it's in there so I go to bed, and then when I open the microwave next morning I get jump scared.
Oh.
That's what I've been saying!
Yeah.
You know...
I said that the other day.
I don't know.
I thought we heard something about peepees.
Oh, 1v3!
What about your peanuts?
Cage catch?
Cage catch!
Oh, it's 20 coins!
I hope I win.
That's a lot of money.
Eh.
Oh, it's this one.
Me too.
We have to catch it.
Oh, this.
Wait, are we working together?
Yeah, I have to...
Like, I have to be the one that presses the button.
Oh!
Oh, and then someone runs away from us.
Yeah, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Yeah, she's still a killer!
There we go.
Alright, we got it.
I hope I win.
Alright, Mara, you better run!
Okay, guys, you guys have to tell me when to press it.
We're coming on now!
Today's my off day.
Okay.
Kill her!
Um, what?
What?
How?
Where was she?
I don't have any money!
You guys have to be easy on me!
You're broken!
I don't...
I can't feed my cat!
Wasn't my idea.
Like, how did she TP out of the cage?
That was...
At the heart of the cards.
Yay!
It's the last turn, so it's like, what do we even do?
Why am I on board, though?
Because you don't have money.
I am...
I helped as much as everyone else did!
You might still win.
You never know.
Yes, last turn!
Okay, look around.
Watch us, watch us, watch us.
Look around.
How do I...
What do I see?
Oh, God.
Oh,
it's on the other side of the planet.
I don't think any of us are gonna catch up to Zen, though.
You never know.
What about the bonus stars?
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, but I think she won...
It's either Fillion or Zen that won the most minigames.
Fuck!
It's definitely not me.
You know...
Wait, I can just take a trip!
Oh, yeah.
You might be close.
Yeah!
If you take the train.
Wait, so, let me see.
I just gotta go, like, uh...
Oh.
Yeah, make sure you go forward.
No.
It's not...
I can't get there.
It's over.
No, it's not happening.
No, I'm good.
Okay.
What'd we get?
What are the...
I'm gonna go here.
Oh, you get to go on a...
You get to go on a date.
Wait.
What?
Don't do it.
What is happening?
Bring me...
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
If I do this...
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Then you guys are gonna win.
And Zen Trey is reverse...
No, Zen's leaving.
Fuck you.
I'm on you.
Exactly what she said.
I'm on you guys.
You're playing me for a fool.
Girl.
Thank God she didn't do it.
I think you are so smart.
Girl.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Golden balls.
She's saying you're smart, because...
Because you fucked up.
Yeah, you fucked up hard.
You fucked up.
Explain what I fricked up!
You'll understand soon.
Oh, I was just saying you were genuinely smart.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Don't...
Also, nothing.
Okay, so I...
What?!
As long as I'm not last...
Eloy!
Game 3 will tell a different story, dookie bird!
As long as I'm not last...
You son of a awful frick!
Bro, I'm getting canned!
I'm getting swapped canned!
I wanna swap servers!
I'll do everything I can to not be last!
What the hell?
Yippee!
I respect it, honestly.
One stop.
Yeah!
You know what's funny?
Doki, you are the main person I am finding this one.
Even if I take it from Zen, there's no point.
I just want to guarantee my placement.
And you hit her with the chain?
I actually had just did everything.
And I get Yoshi, too.
Hey, Yoshi.
If you stole from Zen, you would literally be in first place.
Yippee.
No, I don't have enough money to be first place.
This is an extreme level of petty.
Oh, this one.
Wait, does it even matter who gets Yoshi in this point?
No, it doesn't.
She's just there.
I might matter for Mirrors and Treya because we have one turn left.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah.
So maybe both of you guys can just throw.
Oh.
I would like to personally apologize for this game.
What is this?
It's pretty bad.
Oh, this is the one where you run.
Oh.
How do you eat?
Okay, I probably understand.
How are you guys eating food?
You just have to walk up to it.
Oh, I'm an idiot, I guess.
So are we trying to eat as much food as possible?
Is that a game?
Yeah.
Wait, that's not an advantage.
My teammate- You guys can just take it from me.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
This is- Wait, how is she so- Wait, how is she fast?
Oh, it's the advantage, I guess?
Yeah, it's my advantage.
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, there's a shortcut?
Okay, this basically shows Zen played 60 hours of this.
Like, I can tell that she played 60 hours of Mario Party.
She even played 60 hours of this.
I was like, how the fuck did she know the shortcuts?
Because I really fucking hate myself.
Oh.
What are the apples?
They're the speed moves.
They're not called apples, bro.
What are they called?
Oh.
No.
Wait, so are we trying to get to the end?
Wait, they'll just speed you up.
Yeah.
I thought you looked like them up.
These Zen and her stupid shortcuts.
Slow down.
Wait, can you guys slow down, please?
Oh my god!
No!
Oh.
I need to win, so that I can get the creature.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
You're just like...
Goodbye, Zen.
Hold up, Susan.
It's okay.
Now Zen has Yoshi.
How is she so fast?
Because she does 60 hours of Mario Party!
Stop.
She knows all the...
She literally knows all the shortcuts!
Stop her!
Don't leave her!
I'm trying!
How do I stop someone with 60 hours?
Wait.
No.
I'll come back.
How the fuck do I get up?
What?
Oh!
Baby!
Oh my god.
Don't call it a comeback.
I don't know my map knowledge.
I have no idea about map knowledge.
I'm not the one.
I'm not the one when I do.
Oh god.
I got so confused.
Fuck.
Who, who, who, who, who?
Like, I can't make it.
I was like, Yoshi, why can't you jump high?
Good game.
Holy shit.
Jesus.
Now Mario has Yoshi.
Wait.
Oh wait!
And Zen can't steal Yoshi because...
Wait!
Yoshi's an ally?!
Zen can't steal Yoshi too.
Is superpowers helping you evade taxes.
Yay.
Money!
Well, it's a good thing I was about to win the game.
Hooray.
No IRS.
Jillian, I didn't see you that entire game.
Yeah, the final goal was to collect apples.
So I was, like, staying in the back waiting for them to respawn.
Wait, what?
Amazing number.
Oh, you didn't realize it was a race?
I thought you won the most apples.
I heard someone say that.
I'm like, okay, cool.
I'll get apples.
Oh, you got one guide.
It sounds like they're not apples, Billion.
Billion shot one guide.
I know I got one girl.
There's one of you freaks.
Open.
Yay.
Open sesame.
Yay, coins.
I think Zen got the most coins, too.
I hope that Yoshi gives me a free star.
You have one turn.
It might be a possibility.
Please.
You start with one and you end on one.
Oh, money!
Yes.
Okay.
Nice.
I did.
In the end, I did get 20.
No more.
Last minigame.
I hope I get two bonus stars and win the game.
Excuse me.
That is a big possibility.
You could get the minigame.
I think the minigame bonus is between you or Zen.
I don't think I won that one.
I definitely didn't win that one.
It counts coins from coin minigames.
I hate this one.
What's this?
What?
This is literally just all luck.
Oh.
Choose a key and put it to a door and hope it works.
Yeah.
It truly is Mario Party.
There's literally no skill involved.
It really is Mario Party.
The worst part is... you have to wait for everybody to do it or leave.
I'm gonna win.
Pick me, pick me, pick me, pick me!
Do you wanna go first?
Oh, what if she... I think she could actually get it on the first try.
The square key goes into the square hole.
Yeah, she's gonna do it.
None of them are square, bro.
Square!
Oh, no.
What if it's a circle key?
What if the circle key goes in the square hole?
The square... Oh.
...Idiot...
We're just going in order.
What if it's the triangle... Oh, it is!
It's a triangle key!
Did you win??
Yeah.
No.
Now you can get second place.
Uh... She won!
Yeah, she might actually get the minigame, star.
It's okay, Fillion.
Today's not my day.
I just learned a shape, so this is a huge day for me.
Oh, it's 50-50.
Unlucky.
Alright.
What if?
Yay!
Dude, that's rough.
Goodbye, Fillion.
That is so rough.
Wait, so how long can you get a refund for?
Oh my god.
You can't get a refund for me.
You have to play forever.
No game will ever go on sale on the Nintendo eShop.
That's rough, buddy.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
It's not even a 41.
Hold on now.
You might get another star.
Chat, what have I won?
You could get the mini.
Bonus stars.
You never know.
Yeah, look, that's my entire career.
And it's over.
Oh.
I really, I really stagnated.
You peaked in high school.
Yeah, I really did.
Alright.
Miss Fortune.
Miss Fortune bonus.
Let's get you that bonus.
I think it's... I think it's... Yay!
What?
That's... Yay.
Eh-heh.
Lucky me.
Rich.
Oh wait, that's Zen.
Oh, that's not fair.
It's over.
Game's over.
Yeah.
Zen won.
Game's bugged.
How did I not win the Pity Star?
End it all.
End the game.
Close the game.
Zen picked the game.
Zen wins.
I'm surprised as you are.
This is the worst Mario Party game of all time.
No wonder.
I knew she wanted us to play Mario Party.
I cannot believe you did not get that misfortune star.
Yeah, I'm surprised Fillion didn't get the misfortune.
Cheat.
Why did we let her host a room too?
Damn.
Maybe I shouldn't have stolen her star.
That's fine.
Chance time.
Hey.
Oh, Fillion, you got the Amble Award.
What's the Amble Award?
What is Amble?
Let me see.
I'll look it up.
Um... Amble Award... Mario Party... Yeah, that's how spaces traveled.
I went two spaces more than Zen did.
It says... Um... All I did was get my steps in for an hour and a half.
Apparently it means that you traveled.
Apparently it means that you traveled the least spaces.
No, it's the most.
Jesus Christ.
I'm pretty... You're telling me I've worn the hearts out of everyone and I still got last.
Wait, I'm looking.
I'm looking.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Doki, you could have just... No, if I didn't steal your star.
If I didn't steal your star, I would have been last.
Last, Fillion.
Someone had to be last.
And it wasn't gonna be me.
It wasn't... It wasn't going to meet me, Fillion.
I played the not last card.
Goal achieved.
Yay.
Oh, wait.
No, it is the most spaces.
Fillion, you traveled two more spaces than me.
Thanks.
Yeah, good job.
Good job, everybody.
You lost a lot.
I'm proud of all of us.
I really like Mario.
Yay.
Me too.
Alright.
I wonder what Zentreya's player card looks like.
Wow.
I'm not surprised at the person who chose the game and also created the only one.
I know.
Don't think you need to do that.
Why is it... I'm sure it's... Wait, how do you see the card?
Why is Bowser and Peach standing together like that?
Why...
How do you see the card?
Didn't you hear?
Oh.
Five games left?
No.
Hear what?
What are they here?
Peach and Mario are only friends.
58 hours and 21 minutes?
Nintendo confirmed.
Oh my god.
That's like... You spend like at least two days in... Almost two days locked in a room playing Mario Party.
Yay.
Please.
Kill you.
Oh, I like how Mario... I like yours is... Um...
Should we do one more game since that was one hour?
The loss.
Truly is loss.
Well, you know, I'm pretty busy.
Oh, I think I'll... You might win this one, though.
Who knows?
Because she hates us, bro.
You might win.
Yeah, you might win.
Yeah, you might win this time.
Ah, no.
I think I'm just... I don't know.
I just... I don't think I have time tonight.
Like...
What if I give you the easiest one?
Oh, what if... So Filia's gonna end as the biggest loser.
Okay, Filia, then what if we...
Uh, what if we scheduled another one for another time, then?
Yeah, we can talk about that.
We can do it.
We scheduled it right now.
We could just talk about it.
I want to do it again.
I can't.
Please.
No.
I'm done.
We're doing it.
Oh my God.
You should do the Bowser world.
That was fun.
Sub me out.
I don't want to.
Too late.
I'm done.
No.
I can't do it.
Well, Zenchai is already starting one.
So even if you leave, we're going to have to pick up on it eventually.
Oh, that's crazy.
You guys can.
I'll go find you a sub.
A what?
I'm putting it on the easiest map.
Yeah.
How about that?
Will that make you feel good?
No.
Are we going to play baby mode?
I want to go home.
It's okay.
I got you.
Oh, give her a handicap.
Give her a handicap.
Don't worry.
Can I get five?
You got a good idea.
Give her a star.
No, I don't want to.
One star.
Yeah, one star.
Here you go.
No, I don't want a hand out.
There you go.
That is going to make me get mugged.
I guess we're just going to have to pick this up on another day, man.
I don't want to play.
We're going to do a different day.
Okay, guys, I can find you a sub.
Yeah.
Next week, Mario Party again.
Come on.
You love us.
Next week, next week, next week.
She doesn't like us anymore.
I actually don't think I have time for a whole second game though.
Oh, my God.
Make a wiggler's tree party.
I can't believe you're already leaving us.
I'm sorry.
Damn.
Can't believe it.
Just because she does.
She hates.
You sure?
Yeah.
How many games?
How many rounds is this?
The same amount.
Just ten.
I can't.
I don't have time for that.
It's ok, we can always pick it up next week.
I can find you guys a fourth.
What do you guys think?
And then you guys can play another?
What?
I can find a fourth for you guys, and you guys play another?
I got someone in my chat list.
But there's never a prospect.
I mean, we can do it five turns.
Yippee!
Oh, I won't be.
I'm not free next week.
The week after.
Oh wait, no, I can't do that.
Oh, and then we never meet again.
Next month!
We never saw each other again after today.
I mean, we could do five turns.
Five turns is like, what?
Oh, I can help out that.
I can't.
I don't, I cannot.
I think Fillion needs to go.
Yeah, I think she has to go now.
Yay!
Yeah.
It's ok.
We'll find a time.
Deal!
Alright, how do I, how do I, how do I go, how do I hop out?
Ooh, can I be an AI?
You closed your switch.
Yeah, we go to the party plaza.
Can you guys make me an AI?
We have to go over to yeah.
Oh, frick yeah.
Alright, make me a bot.
Alright.
X.
That was fun though.
Yeah!
Well, fun for me.
It was fun for me too.
I had a great time, guys.
Yeah.
GG's.
Yay.
GG's, everybody.
GG's, guys.
Thank you for taking the L, Fillion.
Yeah, thanks.
It's a lot of work.
So all of us could have such a good time.
Yeah!
It's a great sacrifice for the greater cause, you know?
You did good.
Content!
Thanks!
Don't worry.
That's the Mario Party experience.
True.
Yeah.
Some games are really fucking rough.
We added two more hours to Zen's 60 hour journey in Mario Party.
Yeah.
Kill me.
You did really good, though.
Don't worry.
GG's, guys.
I usually just end around four hours, so going six hours would be crazy work.
Yeah.
Yeah, I literally just don't have the time, but...
Yeah, it was really fun.
Yeah!
Have a good night, guys!
GG's, everyone!
GG's!
Thank you for playing!
Yeah!
Bye!
Thanks, everybody!
I'll see you guys!
Bye!
Bye-bye!
Adios, friends.
Whoa!
Alright.
I sort of missed my premio's delivery, so they were like, we can't deliver it because I was too busy, I guess...
Too busy not being last!
I'll call them later.
Let me swap screens real quick.
Uh...
Oh, I forgot about that picture.
Oh my gosh.
Um, but yeah...
Oh, yeah!
Also, I wanted to add, when I was trying to fix my Switch...
Switch, I unplugged my third monitor, because I was like, what if it's my third monitor?
What if that's the reason why it's not working?
I restarted my PC four times, because I was like, what if I just restart my PC?
Maybe that's why.
It's literally all because of my stupid fucking Switch controller being plugged into my Switch.
I didn't know that was a thing.
If you have your Switch controller plugged in, your game capture doesn't work.
And I didn't realize that.
I was like, fucking freaking out.
And was like, um...
Yeah, literally, like, four hours of just trying to figure out what was going on.
Okay, I didn't want to say it in the beginning of the stream, because I didn't want to kill the mood.
But there was a reason why I was like, super off today.
Um, and also, the original reason...
Okay, I'll let you guys know now, since like, uh...
But the original reason why, at first, I had to push it.
Because originally, we were going to push it for 30 minutes.
Um, was because, like, you guys know.
Um, I had to take Doki to the hospital.
And we, um...
An hour before the stream...
30 minutes before the stream was supposed to start, originally.
I got a call from the vet.
And basically, it's...
It is another disc issue.
Um, so obviously, that was like, a huge thing to...
Um, it was a huge, like, news as well.
Um, but the thing is, I can't do another surgery.
Um, I wanted to update you guys this.
Just cause like, you know, just to let you guys know.
But, I can't do another surgery, because it's at the neck this time.
Um, and they were saying that because it's at the neck, the, um...
Success rate for that is lower.
And it could actually get worse.
Uh, but...
The good news is that...
The good news is that, um...
It's just...
He just is like...
It's just a little...
He's just limping a little bit.
And, um, because of that, it's just more so of just four weeks of medication.
So, he's gonna be on like, a new set of medication.
Um, and, um, it's just literally like, four weeks of rest and meds.
And, it's not...
The disc issue is not in a way where he won't be able to move or anything.
It's more so of like, um, it's just a small limp.
Because they said like, oh, there's no neurological issue.
It's just there is pain when...
On his like, right leg.
And his neck.
So, because of that, um...
Because of that, uh...
He'll...
He'll just need to rest and relax for four weeks.
And, if four weeks...
But the only thing is...
The thing I'm scared about is that...
They said that, um, if four weeks...
If four more weeks, he doesn't rec...
Like, he still feels pain.
Then, like, we'll look into surgery.
And see if that's an option.
So, I'm just hoping that...
Because they said it's an 80% recovery rate.
It's an 80% recovery rate of just rest and meds for four weeks of not moving.
Um...
So, that's why I was...
Obviously, I really appreciate the girls for pushing.
I asked an extra hour...
To?
Because, obviously, I was like, I can't play Mario Party after hearing that.
I...
I was like...
I can't...
I...
After...
I need more than 30 minutes after...
Like, I had to push it out.
Because I was like, I can't play Mario Party after hearing that news.
So, I really...
But...
But while I was doing that, I was trying to get my game capture to work, too.
So, I was like, obviously, I was not having the best day while trying to find my stupid...
While trying to fucking find my stupid game capture.
Because I was like, I got the con.
I'm still trying to troubleshoot my...
I'm still trying to fucking find my game capture, too.
So, I was just like, where the fuck?
I almost, like, decided that, like...
I was going to, like, drive the Best Buy to, like, fucking buy a game capture.
But luckily, I found it in the box of clothes for some reason.
It was in the box of clothes.
Um, but then I had to spend... I got an extra hour, so I was, like, using that extra hour to fucking troubleshoot my game capture.
Because I couldn't get it to work until the last 10 minutes.
The last 10 minutes I was able to get that.
That's why, like, you guys could sort of tell I was, like, I was, like, not locked in.
I was not that locked in today, in terms of, like, gaming-wise, I was...
But, um, but I hope you guys still have fun.
Um, I still kept the collab, because I did want to put my mind off of things.
Um, but, uh, he is getting picked up by the Dog Sitter today.
And, uh, the Dog Sitter, like, is very good at taking care of, uh, Doki, Amber Doge.
So, uh, she's really good at taking care of Dad.
And, like, the Dog Sitter loves- loves him, too.
So, um, she is gonna be looking after him for around two weeks.
So then- and then after those two weeks, he'll be back with me.
And then I'll look over- look, uh, look- look after him for the next two weeks.
So- So, yeah.
No, he deserves to get spoiled.
It's just- it is a lot of monies.
But, like, honestly, like, I'm okay.
That CT scan was fucking $2,000.
But at least, like, now, I know for sure what it is.
And they're giving me a new set of medication.
Um, we're giving- yeah, they're giving me a new set of medication, um, to help with the healing, uh, with the disc stuff.
Um, so yeah, like, I am- I have- I think if- like, I'm gonna say when- when.
I'm not gonna say if.
I'm not gonna say what if.
When he gets better, I'm gonna treat him more like a senior dog.
In a way where, like, I ask him, like- Cause, like, the thing that sucks is that dad really likes- Dad really likes fetch.
And I- I'm sad that, like, he won't get to play fetch the same way he likes it.
So, like, I have to roll the ball now.
So, he can't, like, um, I have to roll the ball instead of, like, actually throwing the ball.
Because he loves running for the ball and jumping up to catch it.
I think that's what caused the issue.
Because, like, when I was playing fetch with him, he always- he loves to, like- Like, even though I try to make- like, throw fire so he doesn't do that.
He does, like, love to run, like, you know, Mach 8 towards a ball and try to catch it in the air.
Um, which I try to minimize.
But, obviously, you know, I can't stop him from doing- being a dog.
So, I'm gonna try, like, to roll- The thing- Okay, this is also- fucks up.
But, like, there are other dogs also playing fetch at the dog park.
And he also tries to chase other balls, too.
So, like, I have to, like- I have to, like- Uh, I guess, like, if I see another- another, uh, owner playing fetch, I have to bring him away.
Because, like, he's gonna play- he's gonna chase after their ball as well- as well.
So- Oh, so he pooped in the hospital.
Because he was a little fucking- Okay, um, okay, I can't say that because he's going through a lot.
But he was a little bitch.
But when I took him to the hospital in the morning, um, he- he peed.
Uh, there's, like, a little area for him to, like, pee and poop.
So, he peed.
And then he was like, I'm done.
And I was like, no, no, no.
You haven't pooped yet.
You have to poop before we go in.
And he's like, no.
He's like, I wanna go inside now.
And I was like, okay.
But, like, no pooping inside.
And the moment I sat down, because I had to fill out a form, this other owner was like, oh, um, your pet's having an accident.
And I literally looked to my side.
And I see him squatting and just pooping on the floor.
And I'm like, are you fucking...
I...
I was just like, mm, in...
Oh, my God.
You're in front of everybody.
You little whore.
Like...
Because I was like, come on.
Just do your little poop.
And then we go inside.
And he's like, no.
And then he, like, like, I don't want to pull on his, like, lead harness, too.
Because, like, you know, I don't want him to, like...
Like, like, like, use his legs too much.
And then he's like, no.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna just...
I want to go inside.
Uh, he wanted everyone...
Yeah.
He wanted everyone to fucking watch.
And I was like, are you fucking...
Um...
Kidding me.
But, no.
For those who are wanting, the cleaner doesn't rearrange my stuff anymore.
She did it one time.
And then never again.
Um...
But I'm glad I didn't go out and buy another game capture card.
Because, like...
Elgato capture card.
Because those are fucking expensive.
So...
I don't know.
The fact that I'm so sad.
I had to actually, like...
I opened my PS5.
Just so I could, like...
Like...
Because I was desperate.
I was like, maybe it's because the HDMI cable is not a console HDMI cable.
So, maybe...
Maybe if I used a PS5 HDMI cable...
Um...
Then it'll work.
And then it didn't work.
I was like, I don't know.
I don't know what to do anymore.
I...
I don't...
Yeah, I spent...
I spent enough money.
Um...
But, yeah.
That's why I was, like, super low energy.
But I still...
You know, I tried my best to...
Have...
Um...
Fun.
And to...
Um...
Tried my best to, you know, talk to...
Like...
Make sure, you know, we still have fun.
Obviously, I didn't want to force anything.
But I still tried my best to, like...
Uh...
You know, make sure it's a fun collab for everybody.
I felt bad rescheduling, too.
I didn't want to reschedule it, as well.
And I really needed something to...
I really needed something to, like...
Uh...
Take my mind off of things.
So, that's why I kept the collab going.
Um...
And also, because, like, this collab...
Uh...
Philly had asked me for a collab for, like...
Three weeks ago.
I think, like, three to four...
Before...
Before July.
She wanted me to join this collab.
But, like...
Uh...
Before July.
But I was, like...
I had, like, Anime Expo.
And then I was, like...
And then, like, my other collabs...
Leading up to this one.
Um...
This was, like, literally the only week where I was free.
Because, like...
After Anime Expo, we had our Emissionary Zero collab.
Which I organized in advance.
Because I organized three collabs in advance.
So, I had, like, Emissionary Zero.
And I had Peak.
And I had Emissionary Zero again.
And...
And so...
Um...
Uh...
So, like...
It was, like...
Like...
I had, like, all of the...
So, they're, like...
I was, like...
Sorry, Philian.
I had all these...
All these collabs...
Uh...
In advance.
I'm sorry.
So, like...
This is the only day I'm free.
Uh...
Which was, coincidentally, my NASCAR week, too.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
Or...
Emissionary...
I don't know.
I don't know what it's called.
I don't know how to pronounce it.
Emissary?
Emissary Zero.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I had, like...
A lot of my collabs...
Um...
Just scheduled it in advance.
So, I was, like...
Sorry!
And so, I didn't want to reschedule it again.
Because of it.
Like...
Because I...
And also, like...
You know, it would have been, like, super last minute, too.
I was, like...
Oh, I didn't want to do that.
I didn't want to...
So, at best...
Like, I'm really glad that they let me... They let me... They let me... Push the collab an hour early.
Just so I could, like, you know, I guess, like, process everything.
But yeah, I had a great time.
It took me a while to get into it, into, like, the collab.
Like, it took my mind, like, you know, lock in.
Well, not gaming-wise.
I was definitely not locked in gaming-wise.
I... The only... I felt like the only... The only game I won was definitely...
Was the fucking button mashing.
Because it was, like, no brain.
Just press the button.
But I felt like I was so slow.
I felt my reaction speed was so slow.
Yeah.
I could feel like I wasn't mashing as fast as I could.
So I was like, oh, man.
I don't think, like, I'm gonna win.
I was like, wait, I won?
And I was just like, wait, what?
Not... Yeah.
Um...
But I felt like my reaction speed was so slow today.
Um... Because I was, like... I guess, like, tired of it, too.
Um...
Yeah, but I was, like, my... The other games, I was...
I was like, I don't know what I'm doing.
Also, it didn't help that I was playing with a monitor on my lap.
Because, like...
I don't know.
Was my stream lagging a little?
I don't... I couldn't tell if the game...
Was my game lagging on stream?
I felt like the game was lagging a little bit on stream.
But I couldn't... I...
I couldn't tell.
There were, like, small little...
Oh, it was fine?
Okay, um...
Okay, so, like, on OBS...
On OBS, the game was lagging a little bit on OBS.
And so, like...
Um...
It would, like...
It would, like, frame jump a little.
So, like, I would have, like...
Like, it would frame jump a little bit.
And it, like, threw me off.
So, I was like, isn't it...
It must have been an OBS thing.
It wasn't input delay.
I... I didn't...
There was no...
There was no input delay.
But like, I could feel the very, very small frame jumps.
But that messed with me.
Like, that like actually messed with me at first.
So I was like, okay, I'll just play with a monitor on my lap.
And then like, but because I couldn't put the monitor in front of me, if I put the monitor in front of me, I can't capture myself because my phone, it would be like, is in the back, basically.
It's in the back.
And so I was just like, okay, I have to have it on my lap.
So at least people can see me reacting.
That's why I had to put it because I didn't have an actual setup to put like, put the monitor in front of me because I put the monitor in front of me.
My phone is behind the monitor.
So I was just like, oh, man, because I usually I usually just play Mario Party on my OBS.
That's how I play.
I actually play Switch games on through my OBS because there's no input delay.
But there was a tie.
I don't know why for today.
Everything was just not going okay today.
Everything was just not my day today.
So I usually play it through my OBS because there's no input delay at all.
But for some reason today, there was like teeny tiny frame jumps and I was like frame drops and I like and I noticed it too.
So when Min was like, the people can only see six... No, that is not fuck.
That is not fuck.
When I can notice raindrops like instantly, that is not... That is fake news.
Like, it like threw me off so hard.
So I was just like, okay, I'll just play with the monitor on my lap.
It's true for me.
I have specialized, okay?
I have specialized.
But yeah, I really appreciate everyone being here.
Being here too, guys.
It really does mean a lot.
I hope you guys still have a lot of fun.
Um, despite my lower energy, uh, and, um, I'm not last.
Yay!
Look, if I didn't steal that star from Fillion, I would have been last because I would have been broke.
So, um, through coin wise, I had to do it, okay?
Like, someone had to be last and it wasn't going to be me.
I...
Someone had to be last.
Uh...
I need one win today.
And that was my win.
Uh...
Anyway, um, I am gonna go now, guys.
I wish I could stay around longer.
But, uh, I have to, um, figure out my...
Uh, I need to figure out my, uh, pre-cooked meals.
So I can actually get it delivered here today.
Uh...
So, I gotta call them and then also get...
Dad picked up by the dog sitter today.
So, anyway, guys.
Uh, I hope you guys had a great time.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, uh, pause, check, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you steal from me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.